il écrit à bout ça tu auras pardon et
son nom écrit en entier contre jefferies
xiang
on va se suivre le match côté côté de
chasse warriors pour le moment je suis à
100% par rien les enfants paris on peut
parier mais en pronostics sur sur les
matchs puisque j'ai fait un grand sans
faute
je n'ai pas je n'ai pas raté j'ai eu que
des bons résultats aujourd'hui je vais
prendre la surprise pour moi c'est le
premier match où je peux me tromper en
fait les autres matches honnêtement
elles mêmes les deux autres ce week end
que j'ai pas à couvert je m'étais fait
mais petit prono de mon côté je m'étais
dit c'est quasi impossible que je me
trompe et je ne me suis pas trompé et
celui d'aujourd'hui c'est le premier où
j'ai un doute en fait les autres
même pas besoin de les regarder c'était
c'était c'était couru d'avancé pour moi
celui d'aujourd'hui
[Musique]
je vais m abdou s'auto rohff mais je
suis pas sûr de moi à 100 % même si pour
moi il est favori mais bon on avoir
quand même vision qui vient de jouer le
le le tournoi là le grand chef tour
entre guillemets écho plus on va appeler
ça un grand danger sur les coups plus
sur internet
donc il est quand même chaud il vient de
jouer contre les meilleurs joueurs
mondiaux après pour moi à doué
et on va l'appeler abdou parce que tous
à tord off c'est un peu un peu longuet
pour moi il est au dessus après
après avoir après avoir il ya un certain
on va appeler ça du suspense ouais on va
appeler ça du suspense aujourd'hui il
peut il peut il peut y avoir un résultat
inattendu c'est c'est possible c'est
possible c'est pas du 95 10 ou 95,5 par
dont 90 à 10 comme les autres matches
encore j'étais plutôt généreux pour pour
les outsider aujourd'hui je dirais c'est
moi je mettrais quand même 90 10 parce
que j'ai réussi je réussis tellement a
pronostiqué quasiment 100% des matchs de
ces petites choses que je suis hyper
confiant sur mes favoris on va dire qu
objectivement ça doit être un 60 40
après bon mois la vue du format de ce
que je connais de mes ressentis de
machin j'irai quand même perdu 85 15 on
va dire sans générosité ni pour l'un ni
pour l'autre
85 15 mai après après tout est possible
comme je disais 'j'ai frictions en plus
cela qui sort d'un tournoi où il a pu
bien s'échauffer il a joué contre les
carlson et compagnie
nakai cetera donc c'est un excellent
échauffement c'est le on va dire série
de 85 74 c'est le premier match qui en
vrai se regardent en fait en vrai
celui-là je suis vraiment intrigué tu
vois du résultat et c'est vraiment
intéressant de voir ce qui va se passer
les six premiers matches avait pour moi
un intérêt extrêmement limités du fait
que le format est loin je répète ces
quatre heures de match quasiment et les
vainqueurs étaient quasiment connu
d'avancé donc ça faisait un peu long
pour un truc dont on connaissait le
résultat avant d'avoir commencé
là c'est le premier match où voilà il
peut il peut se passer quelque chose
mais ça lui yves h 15
disons le favori un homme âgé comme j
pour moi pour moi vision de n'est pas
favori je me trouve quasiment jamais sur
ces speech est ce donc on va voir on va
voir alors je prends des risques sur le
papier parce que je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui doivent penser que
de jong est favori donc sur le papier je
prends des risques alors qu'en réalité
je pense ne pas en prendre énormément
à 22 secondes
donc à des crises juste à fabas vendeur
donc ça je réponds juste et je vais
faire le petit le petit switch à je
faire le petit which hop comme ça
j'avais oublié de faire ça donc la
première partie en temps mais je vérifie
que tout soit bon au moins on est
tranquille
ah oui parce que voilà c'est ça que
j'avais oublié j'étais en train de me
dire je vérifie que tout soit bon
pendant que j'ai eu le message je
regardais sur mon téléphone
c'est le chronomètre que j'ai pas me
voilà c'est ça j'étais en train de me
dire j'étais en train de faire autre
chose en même temps je me suis rendu
compte que j'avais oublié lost thing et
on va mettre le chrono donc c'est une
petite cambridge fring à l'ouverture
pour le moment il se passe pas masse de
cheveux un palace de choses il ya
majorité centre maj majorité des droits
et majorité centrale pour les blancs
contre majorité allèles dame avantage de
développement pour les blancs
avantage de la paire de fou pour les
noirs a très bien joué dans le cinq
dames prend 1,5 fou prend ses six échecs
intermédiaire b franck et prend aux cinq
avantages avantage giang ici alors que
xu zhiyong guillon qui ont du coup il ya
le truc blanc qui s'est mis dessus
puisque je m'étais le chronomètre
ok je vais rajouter le chronomètre
attendez je vais rajouter le chrono 1
puisqu'ils m'ont ils vont tout changer
en fait
et du coup c'est vrai qu'ils m'ont parmi
le chrono s'arrête à moi de le mettre
je mettais pas forcément rendu compte du
problème alors attends une petite
seconde
ouais on va start le chrono et je vais
leur ajouter dans obs ça va me prendre
une petite seconde les gars mais au
moins on l'a on est tranquille pour
toute la compet
au moins c'est fait
s'ils me laissent pas ouvrir le truc me
laissent pas ouvrir le truc comme je
veux voilà donc cette petite finale
avantage blanc bien évidemment parce
qu'il ya le cavalier qui vient fixer les
pions sait il va pas falloir non plus
trop s'endormir côté blanc il va falloir
la gagner mais là le cavalier trop fort
un jeu pareil c'est quelque chose que
vous voyez tout de suite ça et quand on
n'a qu'à jouer quatre héros eux deux il
a gagné la partie
il a gagné 4 suit de re2 c'est une
superbe façon de signifier à son
adversaire qu'on le considère assez peu
way c'est un manque de respect c'est un
peu l'équivalent de crache à la gueule
de quelqu'un en fait en haut en gros
c'est un peu voilà si dans la vie
courante il ya un gars tu vois dans la
rue tu lui crache un mollard à la gueule
en gros c'est un petit peu ça
après c'est une attitude un dunac à tout
craché oui mais bon est-ce que face à un
mec qui fait 120 kg et de la boxe thaï
est ce qu'il le ferait moi c'est la
question que je me pose alors la
question ici c est ce qu a tort quand
des huîtres ou prend des huit qui est
des six cavaliers f5 il faut il faut
commencer à regarder ce genre de
tactique 1 alors là qu'à valider si ce
3e set cavaliers f5 roi ici qui prend g7
c'est genre de truc qu'on peut commencer
à calculer
après ici au pire y aurait roi prend g7
comprend des deux tampons f2 est
sûrement tour f3 mais je veux dire par
là que c'est le genre de combines que tu
commences à regarder
mais si tu me dis jamais bonjour avait
jamais vu tes messages nafti aussi c'est
ton premier message gros attendait la
caméra prédit coccyx on va perdre
ah ouais c'est vrai que guillon ne
l'avait pas comme on gagne cette finale
d'ailleurs
alors j'ai pris le parti de suivre le
match du co table ou s'auto rohff parce
que comme je pourrais pas changé les
calmes
je me dis que le gars qui est qu à ma
gauche semble être le gars qui est en
bas ça me paraissait logique c'est comme
mon lit de gauche à droite pas du tout
de ça ça fait comme ça la caméra buquen
reverse donc il est rentré un peu dans
la vente dont je vous ai dont je vous ai
parlé sans faire le cavalier f5
alors avec les noirs et ce qu'on vient
faire flamber 6 pour défendre c'est
vraiment dégueu mais après si ça défend
sa défense toujours pareil les gars il
faut la gagner avec les blancs mais là
le plan ça va être 3e deux cavaliers 4
et france et 5 c'est un petit peu
imparable donc là il avait un petit
piège sûrement s'étaient tombés quatre
fous bekkat fou prend et on prend un f2
le pion ses 5 îles le père ça s'était vu
et il prend g3 zoug qui met le cavalier
en d3 et qui maintenant va gagner ces
six en force en fait parce qu'ils
protègent f2 il a vu un un coup plus
loin
guillon par après c'est toujours facile
quand tu es gagnant de voir un coup plus
loin parce que toutes les variantes sont
mieux pour toi quasiment donc il faut en
trouver une
dans toutes celles qui sont bien qu'ils
marchent alors là j'ai cinq tours france
et 6 c'est le coup logique tour c'est
s'inquiétait aussi une option 1 et il a
joué roigé c'est donc l'idée clairement
de dabdou c'est d'enlever le fou faire
g4g 3 et peut-être même papillon prend
mais j'ai deux géants dames en se disant
qu'avec les blancs il va faire tourner
ses sept tours prend des 4b 5b 6b 7 et
qui va être plus rapide
j'aime beaucoup le courant f1 de la part
de jong qui vient bloquer complètement
ce plan est maintenant il peut faire
soit roigé un soin tout raciste comme
comme il le fait et sur g4g 3 il
échangera donc tourache un roi eu deux
ouvrages et 2 les deux vont g4 il va
prendre à 7 le roi monté va commencer à
envoyer le jeu lorient mais un échec
pourquoi pas sur roy g5y
les f4 ton geste is matt donc le roi qui
repart et maintenant il va falloir
envoyer la majorité et s'assurer qu'il
ait pas un contre jeux blizzard pour les
noirs mais il semble pas un tour âge
d'euros à tour age ii roi f1 tout rachat
ça qu'il veut faire
bon bah du courage et de tours d 1 et
tours d2 d'accord on comprend un peu
l'idée de contres intéressants
ce qu'il essaye de faire quand même
abdou évidemment ça perd 1 mais je veux
dire par là que c'est intéressant de
poser des problèmes à son adversaire
même dans des positions qui sont foutus
c'est un truc ça pour vraiment que vous
appreniez à faire si vous voulez faire
d'énormes progrès c'est de ne jamais
cédez jamais lâché 1 jamais lâcher parce
que tant sauvera tu vas faire un point
sur 10 ou 12 ou un point et demi sur 10
mais c'est énorme en fait par rapport à
la position publique que tu as et là on
voit que jong issue pour la gagner
peut-être qu'il faut rentrer dans roue
en f1 tout rachat roigé deux tours d 1
tour 17 tours d2 est envoyée mais bon il
va y avoir des jets 3 non c'est chiant
c'est bien ce qu'il fait c'est là dedans
qui rentre justement c'est la position
dont on parlait et là pas de chance pour
lui il a raté un truc d'ordinn bon je me
suis le petit ordi l'ordi données f4
avec l'idée sur pions prend de faire fou
pour un f2 cavaliers prends ton camp des
cats qui était très dur à voir mais qui
tenait d'après leur dis donc il a raté
larnack ultime avec les noirs mais mais
il était à un coup de tenir un truc
complètement foutu donc il a raison de
il a eu raison ne pas lâcher après il
n'a pas trouvé la manière de la sauver
mais il a eu un choc
il a eu un choc pour sauver la game
après bon il était tellement mal que que
c'est déjà inespéré d'avoir une chance
mais il l'a eu
donc c'est pour ça que c'est pas un
manque de respect de la jouer dans la
position était pas si simple que ça à
finir et il a
bien réussi à semer le doute dans
l'esprit de son adversaire après
toujours facile avec l'ordinateur de
dire ah oui mais là tu avais une
opportunité parce qu'il y en avait
qu'une à un moment donné et elle était
très difficile à saisir alors là il ce
qui veut faire c'est essayer de faire un
genre de réseau avec roy gkf quatre
pions prend wife trois peut-être
l'assurera g4 il y avait payé des cinq
cavaliers 5 pardon pour mettre un échec
et gagner le fou c'était l'idée et vous
voyez là réussir mais jeffrey john mack
a mal à la pendule donc à présent ils
recréent y recrée une incertitude encore
il malgré le la défense raté le joueur
ouzbek qui réussit à maintenir son
adversaire sous pression et roi des
singes bien joué lès tours j'aime bien
j'aime bien ce qui fait alors là surtout
reprend il doit y avoir un truc à y
avait tout re 5 très bien joué et
maintenant jeffrey qui met la marche
avant et abdou qui sait qu'il a perdu il
a raté la défense alors ils essayent
encore ce truc là mais il y aura des
sept des huit dames et c'est gagné pour
pour jefferies mais quelle défense 1 du
joueur ouzbek ça je n'ai juste pas si
vous imaginez le niveau des deux joueurs
là au moment au moment de la conclusion
je peux vous dire que c'est vraiment
compliqué à faire que ce soit en attaque
ou en défense ce truc là parce que c'est
vrai que ça a été très bien très très
bien est ce que ceux ci bouger ma caméra
ouais je vais essayer de laver c'est un
peu c'est vrai qu'ils m'ont mis un truc
là pour la caméra qui est toute en
longueur qui est vraiment pas pratique
pour une personne c'est pas moi qui ai
fait le design mais normalement préfère
un cadre on 111-109 verbeek laon
au bout au bord de la crise de nerfs il
va falloir qu'ils se calment le joueur
ouzbek renoncer honnêtement c'est très
très dur là la séquence qui viennent de
jouer alors évidemment quand on regarde
quand on regarde des joueurs comme mvl
naka etc
ils le font à toutes les parties et ils
le font très naturellement ou des cars
alcen etc
mais à mes maîtres des défenses comme ça
et conclure face à de tels défend sa
demande un niveau de jeu vraiment très
élevés c'est extrêmement difficile et
c'est ça qui fait aussi la différence
entre les meilleurs blitzer du monde ce
qu'ils sont on va dire dans le top 50 et
les autres c'est qu'ils ont vraiment une
capacité à défendre
incroyable et aussi une capacité à
conclure face à un adversaire qui défend
aussi bien ils ont cette double capacité
quoi que quand tu joues contre ajoie
parle de mon niveau
même quand je vais avoir une position
gagnante ça va être un enfer pour la
conclure parce qu'ils vont sortir 40
mille tours de magie de leur sac pour la
sauver je vais probablement finir par me
faire piéger
moi je suis d'accord que nos bières bien
qu'il a vraiment une tête d'un gars
sympa franchement ça a l'air d'être un
gars cool
après ça veut rien dire c'est pas parce
que tu es une tête de gars sympa que
t'es sympa mais je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec avec toi cyril soit être
dingue à faux après il est jeune il a 16
ans messes à la tête d'un ado cool ça là
il a la tête d'un ado assez ça c'est
assez cool loin c'est les lunettes je
sais pas si c'est les lunettes ou quoi
mais il a la tête d'un gars poser tous
sympas aussi la tête d'un ado couleurs
assez cool coach ou d'autant
c'est un compliment pour moi un ton ordi
bec
non c'est nos dires bec son prénom c'est
pas un ordi bex et nos dires beck ne
dira bec nos dires bec à tous à tort à
nos dires beck est difficile son prénom
ils veulent quoi râler 2009 deux chaises
comme en blitz a doit être 2006 fidh je
pense 2006 2006 50 c'est pas action qui
a gagné la première 6 exemple gagné la
première mais c'est pas moi qui fais le
score aujourd'hui forcément on ne
s'étonne pas qu'ils aient des fautes
mais 6,6 et c'est jeffrey bien
évidemment juste là aujourd'hui pour
faciliter la tâche ils m'ont donné un
ils ont un peu changé le truc et ils ont
mis les scores sont sont faits par un
mec
faut-il encore regarder les parties je
veux dire vous l'envoie là quand même
rentré le score c'est pas toujours chose
aisée mais oui donc fly ça t'a pas
échappé c'est 1-0 pour jefferies
jefferies qui a filé un pion à pendant
qu'on discutait de choses et d'autres de
la tête de notre bête qui avait l'air
sympa pour l'activité
maintenant c'est vrai que un petit pion
qui arrive en c3 ça va calmer les
ardeurs du joueur américain
il pourrait connaître un bot ça pour ça
ça prend une minute je suis 100%
d'accord bout du rouleau
en fait ils font un fichier dans google
docs qui est remplit petit à petit au
cours du match et je sais pas pourquoi
c'est pas automatisés mais pour avoir un
petit bottes qui reprend le score et qu
il le note
en fait ça va cacher ce week-end a été
repose enfin je te cache pas que pas
assez jeune à part mais bon ça va le
récupérer a graduellement
donc je la fais ces trois des quatre
comprend fou prend donc il ya toujours
un pion plus pour les blancs mais le
pion b2 qui est enquis ans qui en sueur
c'est lucas bonne soirée à toi et bonne
semaine merci manu passé la semaine à
2100 danger en vrai j'ai un peu des
problèmes de santé là
du coup ça ça sent pas du tout la
semaine à 2800 à
ok peut-être tour des uns ou dame g3
peut-être tour d un ondam j'ai trois
tours d1 c'est le coût qui me vient à
l'esprit en premier parce que je fais un
clouage un tout bêtement mais il doit y
avoir un truc je vais regarder alors dix
cavaliers prend b2 il attaque la dame
deux fois et il attaque dame une fois
ils attaquent la tour et sur dame prend
b2 fou prend b2 tour prend des huit web
donc tour à tour des seins ça marche pas
du tout c'est le premier coup que je
regarderai du coup faut enlever la dame
peut-être partie ranger 3 tours 1
ouais tour assez bien des cas il prend
b2 et tu te barres après et il n'y a pas
de découvertes moi j'aurais super peur
des découvertes ma ce niveau là il peut
même avoir sur une découverte suis pas
qui a aidé d'un j'ai une connerie mais
il peut même avoir à il paiera pas trop
investissements lioret dam des trois
vêtements mais
mais sur une découverte un peu bête il
pourrait avoir des tours prend aussi si
on prend 1,6 dame prend aussi ce roi
suite qui prend des caprices des 4es du
fou est roi fou prend v6 ou quoi ici ou
défaut 5 qui rôdent ou ou ce genre de
choses donc tourer en réalité y met la
pression sur le fou et 6 ils menacent
tour pointent aussi si on prend aussi
souffrance et 4 qui est la menace
primaire et ils menacent aussi sur des
déplacements de cavaliers des tours
prend 1,6 pour sacrifier
alors
alors non mais j'ai rien de garavan tout
inquiète pas j'ai quelque chose de chien
qui va durer un peu de temps mais qui
est pas grave mais qui n'est pas acquis
et bénard je n'ai pas j'ai pas je vais
pas mourir dans le mois à venir
t'inquiète pas mais voilà ça va être un
peu ça va être un peu chiant parlant si
j'avais le coc vide ça irait je préfère
avoir le coc vide tu as moins j'aurai
pour une semaine on n'en parlerait plus
du coup il a joué fouet 5
il va faire quoi ok tu peux juste
échangé faire d'alger 3 est à ton pion
de plus mais il n'est pas facile à
convertir parce que vous voyez le 1
contre 2 il va pas être facile à pousser
il est fixé il est fixé le pion b2 il
peut pas faire b4 facilement donc il va
falloir tournicoter allait gagner le
pion à 5 faible et gagner là et gagner
la finale
puis on a cinq qui esseulé alors ils
échangent en c4 il va mettre le quart
ayant c3 mais c'est pas simple à avancer
les noirs vont mettre leur tour en b 4
mais c'est pas c'est pas évident la tour
en bkt super bien que la place et
regarder cette construction en fait
elles n'avancent pas côté blanc le fou
aussi s'ils tapent sur le pion b3 et
c'est extrêmement difficile de mettre la
marche avant alors il va peut-être
essayer de switcher d'attaqué l'ale
roy alors est ce qui va essayer de faire
un séjour est bien faire un cas hisser
cette inquiets des quatre médias pas il
n'y a pas l'air bon la côte est côté
blanc le michael jordan ne revient pas
sur sur les droits les amis alors il
fait dams et 5 alors surprise b3 et doit
vouloir fouiller un cavalier des quatre
un truc pareil
j'imagine ou un cavalier ses sets à un
cavalier c7 ça qu'il veut et menacé de
regagner à 5 tout en attaquant
réussissent donc il veut aller il veut
aller s'en prendre aux pions au pion à 5
et préparer cavaliers c7
oui le score est inversé les gars comme
je vous le disais un c'est aujourd'hui
c'est pas moi qui m'en occupe donc s'il
ya des erreurs c'est normal c'est là
mais vous avez le score n'hésitez pas le
bon score ça peut être celui à côté des
du nom des joueurs voyez je voulais
laisser en fait le petit a10 histoire
d'être sûr de toujours avoir le bon
score au dessus et en dessous de
l'échiquier donc h 6 h 3 les deux
joueurs qui évite les maths du couloir
il va y avoir un cavalier c7 qui va
essayer de rentrer dam des deux donc ils
attaquent la tour et serait que le fou
fait un bon taf qui bloque la case ses
huit ils attaquent b3 ils bloquent la
colonne il va partir pour tour être
prend b3 prise b3 prise b3 et c'est vrai
qu'ils protègent à 5 aussi de la casse
des deux c'est une jolie géométrie là
qu'il a trouvé et surtout reprend b3 fou
prend b3 il veut peut-être essayer de
gagner 1,4 et gagner la finale
carrément ouais c
pas si évident 14 secondes contre 13
essais les blancs qui vont aller prendre
le père pète ici avec dame f5 dams et 8
il n'a pas le choix je pense que je
pense s'y fait pas le père pète ya quand
même un pion de moins il ya le fou qui
va revenir il est obligé d'aller prendre
là nul et grosse défense à un dock jong
qui prend le demi point
alors est-ce qu'on va avoir une
correction au niveau du score
alors qu'on va partir on va transposer
dans une catalane dans cette ouverture
et j'ai l'impression que nos dires beck
se pose des questions
c'est un joueur solide un mur tu as on a
beaucoup parlé de thunder bay comme il
habite comme sûrs parce habite en
ouzbékistan est de savoir où ce bec
mais si c'est pas un joueur qui crée des
choses c'est un joueur qui fait pas de
fautes qui essaye juste de renvoyer la
balle
c'est un genre de joueurs si on faisait
une analogie de tennis un joueur de
terre battue
il renvoie la balle il se remet sur sa
ligne de fond il essaie pas de
construire de deux choses très créative
ou de plans impressionnant il veut juste
jouer sa partie sens sans rien donner en
la continuant de manière simple il
essaie pas forcément de mettre son
adversaire en difficulté
par contre si son adversaire fait la
moindre faute il en profiter il envoie
et xing a 20 ans et abdou sow toorop on
a 16 ans et là on a deux espoirs des
échecs mondiaux là pour la peine aussi
c'est aussi pour ça d'ailleurs que ce
match est intéressant parce que cela ce
sont deux vrais joueurs d'avenir serre
que dans les autres matches de ce pitch
est ce que l'on avait suivi ensemble la
plupart du temps ces deux joueurs dont
on savait pertinemment qu'ils seraient
jamais dans le top 10 mondial
c'était ok c'est désespoir tout relatif
en revanche ici on à jefferies xiang qui
pourrait devenir un
membre du top 10 mondial et à bedous
autographes
même si mur thaci crois pas trop il
aurait le potentiel pour devenir un jour
champion du monde donc on a on a deux
joueurs quand même de premier plan dans
le match d'aujourd'hui qui ont qui ont
un avenir certain dans le haut niveau
des échecs
ce qui est quand même tout à fait
différent de ce qu'on a pu connaître
donc l'ami le fou en d4 et il s'en prend
aux cavaliers c6 est donc aucun relief 6
par non et donc au centre options des
cinq puisque ce cavalier est un
protecteur du centre et il s'est libéré
aussi bien entendu le
le coût de 2,4 donc un centre noir sous
pression si on joue un coup comme fou
aussi ce peut-être que les blancs
pourraient déjà réfléchir à des choses
comme ça alors après il semblerait que
ce soit un pion de plus un petit peu
comme tout à l'heure une victoire à la
pyrrhus
on aurait gagné un pion mais où les
noirs pourrait se placer sur les colonne
centrale et puis m lordat mambé cissé
récupère et b2 graduellement
cependant c'est déjà menaces ont ils
fait faut aussi ce don qui la
considérait comme un joug de montrer que
la perte du pion n'était pas si grave
ici mais quand même champions c'est un
pion un en france on a deux qui comme
futur top 10 on a peut-être marc-andré à
mao rizzi et marco materia pour le
moment qui sont talentueux après la
route pour arriver au top 10 mondial est
longue et tortueuse
mais ça lui ads galak sus un pion c'est
une dame en devenir nous dit à la levée
car est donc il n'est pas rentré un an
la varende que je vous montrais qui
permettait de gagner un pion mais qui
venait pas à grand chose et il se dit la
menace est plus forte que l'exécution
c'est à dire je n'ai pas pris un pion je
ne les ai pas pris main maintenant mais
peut-être que je vais le prendre par la
suite
alors attendez en fait ce qu'ils ont
fait c'est qu'ils ont dû mettre les
caméras dans l'autre sens de lorsque
c'est ce que ce que je me suis ce que je
viens de me dire en fait ils ont dû se
dire qu'ils allaient qui faisait comme
ça ils ont dû normaliser le fichier pour
tout le monde et ils ont décidé de
m'exiler à gauche c'est con quand même
on va faire ça comme ça ils ont du sens
normalisé un seul de fichiers ils ont dû
se dire qu'ils allaient faire comme ça
donc pendant que je réglais ça il s'est
passé quoi
moyer échange a eu quatre donc là il
menace vous prend à chaud c'est donc
normalement tu joues h6 ici parce que
j'ai si ça fait super peur avec un fou
déjà en d4
ou peut-être qu'il réfléchit adam prend
à deux les ch 7
ça paraît très dangereux quand même
comme robin des bois les beats sur
internet où les tourelles c'est pas
pareil c'est vrai c'est deux choses
différentes c'est exactement comme comme
si tu compares au tennis jeu sur gazon
et la terre battue comme on parlait de
tennis c'est deux choses différentes
après y'a pas une discipline qui est
forcément mieux ou moins bien que
l'autre mais ces deux manières de jouer
un petit peu différente
donc en vrac les noirs sont moins bien
ces visuels
il ya toutes les pièces blanches qui
sont super bien placé les tours sur les
colonnes ouvertes les fout plein centre
la dame en c2 bien placé mais il fait
ces cinq pirates à oublier ton téléphone
à ton âge ans on m'a écrit exactement
donc merci à dc galactus pour le prime
donc ce fou prend ses 5
est ce qu'il va être joué non france et
5 fait la question c'était tour ses huit
peut-être qu'ils jouaient le clouage est
sur b4 dame prend à 3 donc il a fait
pousser 3 le chien qui est venu là je
suis là je suis un je suis en complet
[Musique]
contre miami chat tu vois tu vas tu vois
tu vas tu vas tu va m'aider ou est tu va
m'aider une petite seconde me charles
michel qui comprend complètement la
position ennemie chan comprend tout mais
il faut quand même faire très attention
micha donc échangeant des huit fait fou
c'est fou et 5 aces qui va les voir x fi
souhait et a su peut récupérer le chien
ça vraiment vraiment un énorme coup de
main mais la porte
ça serait vraiment un énorme coup de
main merci j'ai juste très très peur
qu'elle mange le fils de la fibre c'est
extrêmement dangereux
c'est extrêmement dangereux on peut on
aurait pu perdre internet à long terme
si elle avait mangez le si elle
sectionne le fils de la fibre qui est
très fin ça pourrait être très dangereux
donc il a fait fouet 6 il s'en prend aux
fous fous ces trois entre guillemets ça
va échanger il a réussi à ne pas perdre
deux pions avec les noirs il va échanger
en c3 alors là il va faire fou des
cadres imagine autour des 4 d'ailleurs
est-ce que tour des quatre marche
puisque tour des quatre ça donne encore
plus envie
si ça marche la fée d'amd dam des singes
aurait pas eu envie il faut prendre si
on prend ou là ça c'est dangereux
un tour h43 g7 ont gk3 h 8 tours j'ai
ici ces genres de choses auxquelles il
faut faire attention mais surtout rashka
tri la dame d un échange les dames et
roy g7
c'est son idée en vrai il veut d'âme des
uns au prochain et sur trois g2 pour
éviter lifesize aussi offert tour eu un
tournant et forcé ici pour jouer le gain
toi
c'est le meilleur il évite dan bien pour
jouer le gain c'est le mieux le roi est
faible à long terme
bref cette j'imagine
il protège la case h5
est-ce que tu mets le pion h5 ou pas ici
ouais c'est je pense j'aurais aussi et
maintenant est ce qu'on fait d'art f5
tour des 5
il fait tour 17 ils couvrent à 7 il va
avoir un problème un jour ça va être c5
je pense dont il fait d'un f 5 ça c'est
bien joué tour des quatre énormes à lens
ce dont nous à part les murs pas s'il
défend très bien genre de position
maintenant dam des cinq peut-être le
retour je sais que vous les dames des
cinq tours 1
d'accord il place il place ses pièces
comme ça il défend le pion s'il ya
échange ça va tenir tranquille et
maintenant les affaires tour des 5
f5 tour à 4 tours 17 tours à 5 tours
c'est cette il tient tous là il va
remettre la tour en d5 les blancs
peuvent pas faire ce plan de roy f3 f4
wager 5k leroy qui va courir en 9 6 et
il va tenir là nul il a beaucoup de
pions faible et se moulent mai mais en
fait tu peux pas les toucher enfin tu
peut les toucher mais la tour peut les
défendre simultanément est là il prend
b2 prise à s'être trois tours et chaque
intention paroisse f4 y aurait eu cinq
matches ça ils le voient et maintenant
tout reprend à 3 tours france et 5 c 3
contre 3 c'est complètement nul mais à
vous voyez nos dires beck qui veut quand
même joué le gain il est très très
chiant voilà ça va faire un nul c'est
vraiment le type de match auquel je
m'attendais à un an dire bec très solide
pour ça que la première partie peut
coûter cher
jamie le message avant les change d'état
oui je suis un petit peu en décalé
puisqu'avec chasse comme comme ils
veulent retransmettre sur youtube et
twitch ça ça fait que le décalage est
pas 2,5 10 secondes mais plutôt de 30 ce
qui est assez pénible mais bon c'est
comme ça c'est comme ça il n'y a pas de
lag
sinon c'est c'est juste que comme ils
veulent frimer sur les deux plateformes
ça fait 1 ça fait un différentiel comme
ça moi ça me plaît à titre personnel pas
du tout parce que je trouve que le
stream c'est c'est l'instant tenai
l'instant pénalité non le mot doit pas
exister mais vous m'avez compris et
avoir un décalage aussi aussi grand et
assez pénible comme ça un peu moins on
peut moins faire d'interaction et je
m'en excuse
enfin je m'en excuse je signale au chat
que si parfois je suis en retard ou vos
messages ne colle pas mes réponses ne
colle pas avec ce que vous avez dit
c'est à cause de ce problème
instantanéité ça existe ça je suis au
dessus de tout bon du coup là juste pour
revenir sur l'ouverture on s'était un
ruisseau limo un fourbe et 5 dans la
sicilienne et là c'est intéressant cette
prise avec le pion avec le pion g est ce
que ça te permet d'envoyer à 4,5
éventuellement de renvoyer un pion à f4
et de faire des rois h un tour g1 et
d'envoyer donc c'est eux c'est pas mal
on est bon on est tout bon on est tout
bon est ce que ça marche bien de partout
et donc à la suite de ce match on aura
les parties pédagogique avec avec notre
cette base est à nous tous on en a qu'un
nom que c'est proprietary zay 7 mazet
bon du coup c'est assez logique ce qu'il
a fait c'est des prises et ed l'idée
c'est que ce qu'on voudrait avoir comme
structure ces genres un truc comme ça où
les pions f ils sont complètement débile
puisqu'ils peuvent pas avancer et ils
vont se faire fixer bon je joue mal pour
les blancs à l'express à l'expression
des pressions de vagues exprès mais il
dit sur alex très bon ça ce sera un rêve
pour les noirs avec les pions f qui sont
complètement immobilisés qu'on va
pouvoir attaquer tranquillement
évidemment les blancs sûr qu'elle prend
des saints qui ferait pas un truc pareil
ferait cavalier c3 il s'en prendre aux
cavale cavaliers prend qui on prend il
essaierait d'envoyer des 5.5 pour casser
tous à un genre fouet ses attaches 5 qui
on prend et je sais pas moi des cinq des
six peut-être si déjà donc en gros
c'était pas possible mais c'est l'idée
des noirs je vous montre des variantes
illustrative où je montre des mauvais
coups alors maintenant que le fou est
parti en f1 est ce que qui est prend des
s'inquiète un coup il veut faire f 5 es
fou j'ai deux au moins c'est simple le
fou protégera le roi il attaquera dans
le fion kétou sur sur le pion bessette
et f simple ça c'était sur ses shows de
night 1
ces shows the night
c'est chaud de knight
ce qui m'inspire on prend un but 6 1
c'est très bête sur cavaliers c'est
celle je pense que ça va être une
catastrophe intergalactique
peut-être à base d'oeuf wef 4 ou je ne
sais pas qui c'est ça je regarderai même
pas il fait foulée 4 ça c'est
intéressant parce qu'au moins sûr puis
on prend ici la foux prend 20
donc il va échanger rock puis on prend
1,6
si on prend un but six tours prend aussi
sa gagne un pion quand même mais il ya
la case f4 pour le cavalier m'a
d'ailleurs il le fait pas et on
éventuellement un éventuel jeu dangereux
pour les noirs d'encaisser 3 il n'aurait
pas pu faire fut empreint f5 ici ils
voulaient qu'elle prend des cinq dames
prend des 5 fu j'ai deux très compliqué
hein d'amd 8 pour protéger le cavalier
c'est vrai que ça pouvait être le
cavalier mevel pouvait se retrouver mal
donc il a fait cavalier c6 il revient
vers le centre et il s'en prend aux
pions des 4 mais ce qui va prendre le
pion aux six maintenant non il ne prend
pas
c'est vraiment très complexe donc
toujours pareil inquiet prend ces trois
pions france et 3 puis on prend un f5 il
va y avoir des dessins qui est ça va
être pénible et salut à altea 64 est ce
qu'ils vont en cours à ce niveau ou pas
ça dépend des joueurs
alors j'ai vu tout à l'heure que nos
dires beck a déjà l'impression qu'il y
avait des pommes à côté lui alors je
sais pas si c'était des pommes séchées
peut-être ou des carrés de pommes je
pense et des carrés des petits carrés de
pommes qui s'était coupé à l'avance pour
manger pendant le match
intéressant aux positions ce comprend
aussi ce qu'on peut avoir d'autres de
chypre en d5 et dames f4 hockey dont kim
et merci à d'adhara de bure pour le sahb
il décide de jouer la structure du coup
symétrique ici mais il a quand même le
pion à f/5 qui qui peut devenir une fait
place à long terme
ce cas les noirs vont blindés leurs
pions et si réussi à faire car a lieu
sept bonds il attaquera la cavalier huit
cavaliers f6 ça peut être pénible 1
j'aime pas jouer genre de truc avec les
blancs parce que tu as l'impression
d'avoir un tel d'avoir un retard à long
terme à cause de sion f5
après ces joueurs sont des funambules 1
ils sont ils une telle force de calcul
une telle force tactique qui sont
capables de de tenir des problèmes
stratégiques comme celui ci à très long
terme
en jouant de manière offensive tout le
long est-ce que tour 5 et une idée oui
mais je pense que ça marche jamais mais
c'est une idée way et je pense qu'il
n'ait pas pris la paperie une fois e6
ouais il n'a pas dû vouloir y semoule à
ouvrir la colonelle j'imagine c'est pour
ça qu'il n'a pas pris une fois on
réussisse il a dû penser que c'était
dangereux d'ouvrir cette colonne f
damages six as assez bien joué
d'ailleurs qui jongle en sueur face à ce
coup cherpion prend il ya dame prend un
f6 bien évidemment et sur dame prend il
a calculé tour h3g 5 et peut-être des
fous prend des cinq ici parce qu'il n'y
a pas tout reprendre à cause de dames
point f8 et il n'y a pas d'âme prend à
cause de dames price est donc c'est un
coup de fouet qui avale et prend des
quatre ça c'était encore une autre prise
et surtout rage trois dames g7
mais peut-être qu'il peut y avoir des
trucs avec des age 2 e df e et des tours
7 à la fin c'est hyper chaud jean retour
h3 d'alger cette prise prise prise
prises et et tours 7 on reprend bessette
c'est sûrement ce qui va se passer en
position extrêmement complexe et de les
deux hommes jouent vraiment très bien
franchement ça joue vraiment bien après
c'est sûr si on avait un top mondial
type maxime icart ou quoi en face ce
serait ça irait plutôt dans le sens d'un
joueur du top mondial mais je trouve que
le niveau est quand même très élevé pour
ce match et c'est pas du tout la même
limonade que ce qu'on a connu pour les
six premiers matches de ce pitch juniors
où les matches étaient quand même très
déséquilibrée et on n'atteignait pas ce
niveau mais là ton courage c'était
maintenant qui est mieux et ben moi je
prendrais les blancs je ferai tout
rachetant h7 et je prendrai les blancs
et bonne soirée videsh est ce que les
joueurs voient le visage d'autrui
peuvent l'ouvrir s'ils veulent mais je
pense pas qu'il le fasse tout race est
maintenant va être joué autour des 7 way
d'euros f1 kireev 4 ha c'est très bien
joué ça il défend le pion des 5 et
peut-être qu'avec le roi plus actif il
peut faire quelque chose c'est compliqué
à tour ces vies très bien joué encore
menace maths en un amas temps de mes
menaces maths et du coup grâce à ça ils
s'activent le carélien f4 était bien
trop fort et je tais tu me trompes et
inception qui va le gagner ce match il
me semble un poil plus fort biyong
tout cas là il a il a réussi à dominer
le le momentum alors sûr qu'il prend f2
il ya roi c'est un tour eux deux il va
récupérer à 6 ça doit aller c'est ce qui
va être joué d'ailleurs bon il fait
pousser 2 qui est l'autre option entre
guillemets pour prendre g6 et sur
cavalier e 4 il va probablement jouer
vous prendrez tour prend à 6 août on
prend assise direct alors il va faire ça
les tours pranger 63.6 il a déplacé le
cavalier et maintenant la position va
être complètement égal cependant
attention il ya paroisse b 3 kgs c5 et
paroisse à 3 tours prend ces deux ça
peut représenter un certain danger et
ils ont fait nul une nouvelle fois et
donc on en est à deux et demi un ennemi
c'est toujours cette première partie un
que abdou paye finalement alors il
transpose dans une car au can cette fois
ci avec les blancs à ça ça m'intéresse
si on joue à vente avec g6 que choix
c'est ce que je pense aussi très bon ici
dans cette position avec avec les noix
fou g7 rock et 17 qui a et b ci c'est
une langue que j'affectionne avec les
noirs même si elle a pu avoir des
rebondissements théorique un peu
désagréable tu y avait eu deux cas il y
avait quatre tours ces huit c'était beau
et un s était en partie donc très facile
à voir un mail à la vitesse d'exécution
est assez impressionnante
donc les blancs qui veulent tenir leurs
pions mais y'aura du fou g4 dans la
théorie à l'ancienne en fait on
réussissait à
on réussissait à récupérer le pion en
force mais comme je disais je connais
pas forcément les derniers
rebondissements théorique voyant ce sont
des belles parties zozos de la mañana
aujourd'hui alors on rejoue cette
structure symétrique et tuant même
question est ce que le pion est vraiment
attaquer ou pas parce que sur pareil
quand on va le prendre
ça peut poser problème est fou et six
cavaliers f4 c'est désagréable parce que
ce cavalier ils attaquent e6 et ils
attaquent des cinq risques fouache 4 bon
ça ça se regarde un déjà
ça ça se regarde
la tour prends des quatre reprendre du
fou et ce genre de final qui doit être
nul en 6 e admettons je montre justin
pour vous expliquer là on veut rentrer
en d2 avec la tour et pour attaquer f2
et b2 et cette finale là elle est nulle
théorique
donc c'est pas assez pas dit qu'en
gagnant depuis on réussisse à gagner
quoi ce grave puisqu'il ya qui est
propice maintenant bas surtout qu'il est
prend aussi soin est fou et 3 la
structure noir est quand même assez
pourri un mât après le pion aux 6 à rire
et sur la colonne le pion g6 fait que
les cases blanches peuvent être à fond
affaibli
les blancs sont mieux c'est sûr
meilleure structure de pions père de fou
disons que sort mieux d ouverture 1
c'est évident qu'ils aient b5 c'est
peut-être malin c'est un truc
thématiques dans ses positions pour 58
kg prend à cette ut déstabilise le
cavalier à b6 donc c'est un coup assez
logique
donc comment est-ce qu'on se débrouille
surtout à huit genres pour défendre ya
quand même qu'il prend à cet enfant à
cette dame prend b6 puisque on tue le
défenseur du cavalier ah non là c'est
compliqué pour nous dire bec nord dire
mec qui commence à être dominés de plus
en plus un je trouve que il résiste très
bien parce qu'il est qu'à un point
derrière mais je trouve qu'il est qu'il
est quand même assez dominé je ne sais
pas ce que vous en pensez de votre côté
côté chat d'alain côté de sa canne qui
est venu là je pas ce que vous en pensez
côté chat mais je trouve légèrement
dominé quand même donc et c4 qui est
prend à sept îles a touché la tour qui
est prend 2,3 mais voir juste f 33 et le
cavaliere va revenir peinard en b5 et
ses trois essais un pion de +1 cia yvan
qui va partir un jour en colonna ouais à
si c'était possible mais ça doit être
d'autres problèmes qu'à rallier à cette
on a attaqué la tour quand même et on
s'en prenait aux cavaliers ce qui semble
un petit peu pénible mais ça lui jérémy
finalement on peut dire que cap dou dans
ce match et un style assez similaire au
mien
malheureusement pour lui il souffre dans
les ouvertures il a un peu moins bien il
a beaucoup de beaucoup de poubelles il
réussit tant bien que mal à aller
défendre mais on sent qu'il est sur le
reculoir
ça peut être dangereux sur un match long
ça peut ça peut ça peut être très
problématique
et en plus il a un peu moins bien autant
tout le long en fait c'est ça ressemble
vraiment à mon style pourri h5 idée
c'est sûrement flash 6
tout cas j'imagine un qui veut venir
attaquer ce pion mais là c'est lui qui
se fait toucher en premier mais il fait
qu'à alléger 4 et sur fou prend il veut
fouache 6 c'est malin ce qui fait en
fait il veut utiliser le fait que les
pièces blanches soit un petit peu
bloqués à l dame pour contre attaquer
les droits religieux est très fort à ce
soir c'est vrai après il a quatre ans de
plus cinq ans vous imaginez cap doux et
plus jeune de quatre ans c'est quand
même un sacré un sacré morceau un mois
je le trouve vraiment très doué ce
joueur ouzbek
mais surtout prendre 5 il veut avoir
fait prendre trois rois chain qui est
cavalier f2 c'est bien joué
c'est encore 35 minutes de trois plus un
mais c'est vrai que la partie et devient
très complexe
ces deux pièces blanches sont loin mais
il a des trucs comme dame g7 way
la dame qui va arriver alors l'ordi
donné un grand avantage noir après dam
des huit dames h4 mais c'était quand
même dur à voir d'alger s'est tous
rêvent de leurs dix pensent que c'est
mauvais mais l'idée on la comprend c'est
fou pranger quatre tours angers de roy
pranger de dame prend g4 et on est
complètement dans la mer droit agenda
mef 3g un airois roi à cet endroit je
suit avec avec ton g8 qui arrive au
prochain ah non mais c'est hyper
dangereux en vrai lord il faut faire fou
prend tout reprend roi h un tour prend
g4 et venir contre attaque et je le long
de la colonne jet ski est trouvable un
pur pour jefferies mais c'est trouvable
parce que c'est la seule option c'est
parfois quand je vous dis qui on peut
avoir de la réussite ou de la chance
c'est qu'en vrai c'est la seule option
de fer rouge et quatre tours j'ai droit
à agen est au pied du mur en fait tu vas
trouver par force
ouais tu vas trouver parce que tu es
obligé et du coup on peut dire que dans
le dans la force de calculer dans la
construction de la partie là c'est
plutôt abdou qui a été au dessus mais il
se prend le truc où il ya une seule
défense et le truc c'est que tu es
obligé de la trouvais ça c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment le manque de réussite
une seule défense mais mais quoi quoi
que tu fasses tu la trouveras pas ce que
tu as vraiment pas le choix
bon alors après ça reste complexe 1 ça
reste très complexe parce que là les
noirs menace d'un f3 matt est d'alger de
maths et là encore de manière forcée il
va trouver le truc d'ordi il ya un seul
truc qui tient ses cavaliers fc3a cette
dame ces deux tours j'ai
iis et cavalier e 5 qui va attaquer la
dame compte relève 3g 2e 4 mais là c'est
vraiment la réussite maximum pour que
jong un là c'est terrible il avait
absolument rien vu et il se trouve qu'il
a ça ado dire mec qui le c1 que son
adversaire n'avait rien vu mais il se
trouve qu'au bout de la variante force
et c'est lui qui gagne
ouais ça c'est terrible ça c'est
vraiment vraiment difficile à la lie se
repassent la partie dans sa tête il sait
comme nous à ce qui s'est passé il sait
qu'il a mieux joué et il sait que son
adversaire est une réussite maximale
c'est comme ça ça arrive mais ça
psychologiquement c'est pas facile ça
psychologiquement c'est pas évident
c'est pas édition on l'a bien vu à la
caméra aussi qu'il était vraiment
content d'avoir ce petit ce petit tour
de passe passe avec le cavalier terrible
c'est cruel
c'est très cruel c'est la dure loi des
échecs mais c'est comme ça ça quand les
jours où tu as de la réussite ça se
passe bien quand on n'a pas ça se passe
mal
c'est comme ça c'est la dure la dure loi
des échecs qu'on parle de chance parfois
aux échecs n'y a pas de chance aux
échecs voilà c'était un c'était un
exemple précis où en fait le truc semble
forte pour les noirs tu vois pas de
défense ton adversaire n'a pas vu la
défense non plus il rentre dedans parce
que il en est complètement obligé en
fait depuis très loin et il se trouve
qu'il ya un truc qui gagne il a loupé
d'un des huit le coup de l'ordi mais bon
pour voir tout ça et comprendre qu'à la
fin et avec arrêt lieu 5 qui gagne c'est
quand même pas c'est quand même pas
facile hein à la longue il aurait
sûrement eu la défense oui mais bon en
longue tu as de la chance aussi du coup
c'est les trucs incroyables arrive plus
loin dans les variantes
c'est comme ça aux échecs parfois quand
les joueurs ont un niveau très très
similaires il faut un petit peu de
réussite et pour le moment elle fuit
elle fut un petit peu abdou
bon encore une nouvelle fois ils se
retrouvent pas très bien en ouverture
j'ai l'impression que auquel à son
cavalier à 4 x 3 qui sont maps capa vous
prendrez 6 en fait ce que j'ai encore ce
cas puis on prend 1,4 c'est compliqué
pour a pour abdullah il va pas fort
complètement craqué
attends ya pas un problème f prend dame
prend ya pas il n'y a pas juste une
pièce et des 5 es fou prend à 3 ok
craquage craquage psychologique du
joueur ouzbek voilà clairement le joueur
ouzbek rac1
maintenant là il a craqué sahil a pas vu
c'est sûr voilà rien un coup que je vois
pas moi mais il va jouer la pièce de
moins mais à pas ce qu'il va être obligé
mais ça ils n'avaient pas vu c'est sûr
difficile pour le joueur il le joue et
des 53 des français si c'est sûr que ça
va pas du tout ouais non il n'avait pas
vu c'est sûr c'est évident parce que en
fait sinon tu continues à jouer tempo là
c'est sûr puisque puis on prend ces six
tata de toute façon des fouets f53 je
suis de faim c'est juste une pièce en
fait non mais xiang la tactique il a vu
tout de suite mais juste tu as cinq
minutes à la pendule ton adversaire fais
ça tu sers mal de prendre ton temps puis
on prend 1 4 des 5 il a vu immédiatement
diongue il a il a marqué un temps
d'arrêt parce que parce que voilà
surprise et salue mdd salut kml style
assez complètes ont fini
et ouais j'avais joué un peu la surprise
aujourd'hui à tout ça tu auras vieille
bien que ça peut être un match serré et
le scénario de match même est très très
très très très défavorable je souffre
non c'est bien là ce que fait mme jiang
il a réussi à faire l'écart pris la
raison ne pas abandonner un tu dois un
petit peu la jouer encore en blitz mais
là il n'a même pas pris le pion c6 je ne
sais pas où il a pas pris ces 6 kms
quand il le prend mais ils repèrent un
tempo
c'est dur hein ça compte pour les lots
de chasse comme antonin l'univers h
ça compte pour les lots de chasse comme
mais pas plus sain de toute façon cfa au
même titre que toutes les compétitions
amicales qui jouent sur internet en ce
moment et qui n'ont finalement pas un
intérêt énorme non plus surtout de par
leur profusion
après si ça peut rapporter de l'argent
aux joueurs c'est déjà pas mal
pas de choix de son abaya quand même eu
des vraies compétitions là qui ont
repris comme la bundesliga
plusieurs faits deux vidéos sur les
parties de maxime est ce qu'elle est
confiante jsk mco pour les lots finhan
aucune asie à part laïla of men mais ça
c'est une condition de chaises comme
mais qui joue en réel et qui cette année
était qualificatif pour les candidats
d'ailleurs
donc c'est je pense le la compétition la
plus prestigieuse organisée par un
parent site internet après je peux me
tromper un bac es lagarde s'en sortent
web c'est fini la bundesliga va durer
cinq jours
mais oui le club de bas qui aiment vail
a fini champion d'allemagne
voilà en fait il veut juste échangé les
dames avec les noirs et gagner avec sa
pièce de plus un pour un joueur de mon
niveau ce sera encore très pénible à
gagner pour les blancs contre un mec
comme nos dires bec je sur est à 200%
pour un gars du niveau d'oxygène
c'est assez simple et à caruana qui veut
dans le même club que mv al exactement l
ademe
11 on dirait qu'ils gagnent les
quillards des dames rouge et 4 c'est
logique un cycle où il veut échanger et
affaiblir le roi ne faut pas qu'ils
jouent trop vite
jefferies et merci à gaby gaye pour
l'abonnement de niveau 1
jefferies qui comprend pas ce qui vient
de faire là parce qu'en réalité après
qui avait b6 si vous ne savez pas jouer
trop vite ce qui est peut-être juste
pour ces trois qui potentiellement
pouvait bien finir la partie
après ça reste complètement gagnant 1
y'a pas le feu au lac
aulas xiang comment tu le sais que
l'abonné ce cas soit être aussi
attractive ils ont de l'argent ils ont
beaucoup d'argent ça souvent faut pas se
poser de questions c'est qu'une question
d'argent systématiquement presque le
sport de haut niveau malheureusement
c'est juste une question de moyens
après je crois que le le partage de
l'argent dans le sport en allemagne et
plus et plus équitable ce qui fait que
je crois déjà avoir entendu parler de ça
il ya aussi les sponsors comme greinke
qui filent beaucoup d'argent quand il
eut beaucoup des changes mais de façon
ça laisse une pièce de plus
qu'avait lieu deux hivers pu engranger 2
et on prend des 6 et c'est une pièce net
de plus
ouais ça assez simple à gagner
franchement ça pose aucun problème
d'après abdou peut aussi un peu profité
de la partie pour récupérer mentalement
donc c'est pas bête de la continuer de
jouer des coups alors ça ça mûrit ce qui
est moins d'impôt en allemagne ça
devrait plutôt aller en faveur de moins
d'argent pour des loisirs comme les
échecs normalement
ce que les échecs c'est pas quelque
chose de rentable du tout j'espère
gagner du temps il ya une seconde de
rage ou un parcours comme indiquée sous
le nom des joueurs d'avoir des fouets
fin échec fou prend h3 qui vont arriver
ou tour f2 il va se faire mater kg 5
pour cavaliers f3 et la fougue quatre
essais maths on sent à bout quitte il
tint il lui faudra un mug de l'abbé ap
je pense pour pour se remettre la caméra
vais leur dire que c'est dans l'europe
de l'est et plus sain de gagner sa vie
avec les échecs
déjà qu'il n'avait jamais vécu en europe
dès l'ès 2 laisse donc je suis pas à
quel point on peut vraiment savoir
je n'ai pas vu habitants russie juge pas
mais il se trouve que oui il se trouve
qu'il a raison mais c'est pas du tout
lié au fait de la notoriété des échecs
pourquoi c'est juste lié au fait que
quand tu donnes des cours en fait en
russie c'est un métier qui est
relativement mieux payés que en france
par rapport au reste de la population en
fait
donc c'est pour ça qu'en russie cité
preuve d'échec ou quoi était salariée
dans une fédération quelque part tu va
rapidement avoir un salaire moyen de
[Musique]
de la population alors qu'en france
c'était preuve d'échec dans un club où
quoi tu vas avoir un salaire assez assez
bas alors après en france tu peux donner
des cours à côté pour compléter ce qui
est quand même un avantage que tu peux
pas vraiment faire en russie
tu aurais dû faire preuve d échec en
russie magna ont peu fait ben 3 ft
après la 6ème après personne n'a de
sécurité de chasse hornet qui leur en
russie donc si tu compares par rapport
aux autres professions en russie en fait
les profs d'échecs où les joueurs
d'échecs sont pas moins bien loti après
su qu'on par un prof d'échec en france
ou en russie le prof d'échec en france
va beaucoup mieux vivre que le prof
d'échec en russie mais on va dire que
par rapport à la population
enfin c'est jusqu'à un écart de niveau
de vie entre les populations en fait ma
en russie un prof déchets qui va quand
même être payé peut-être entre 70 et 90
mille roupies site est pas trop mal
établie ce qui est l'équivalent entre
900 et 1100 euros ce qui doit être à peu
près le salaire moyen là bas ce qui est
pas mal
après tu lis beaucoup moins bien qu'en
france avec qu'avec un smic mais bon
comme tout le monde vit comme ça en fait
c'est la norme
un prof en général chelsea en être qui
leur est plus estimé je dirais mise à
part dans l'éducation nationale où les
salaires sont pas du tout élevé en
russie par rapport à la france mais dans
le privé way pour tous les trucs comme
ça oui je dirais pas non c'est compliqué
donc c'est difficile de traiter cette
question de manière aussi simpliste que
de dire les joueurs d'échecs vivre mieux
en russie je pense qu'il beaucoup mieux
aux états unis
je pense qu'en moyenne les gens vivent
beaucoup mieux en aux états unis qu'en
russie dans tous les cas mais bon ça
peut être difficile à expliquer un
américain
maintenant on ne gagne pas par les armes
au souk à kazan mais je crois que dans
la moyenne en fait preuve d'échec tutu
gagne plus ou moins normalement ta vie
en rhuys enfin tu vas pas gagner des
milles et des cents mais je veux dire ça
va aller en fait
après y'a pas de bonne ou de mauvaise
situation apparaît le joueur d'échecs
d'europe de l'est pourquoi sinon une
meilleure école d'échecs qu'il travaille
plus sont plus travailleur
donc ouais ils ont une meilleure école
ils travaillent sont plus travailleur et
ils ont peut-être plus de joueurs qui
jouent de base donc le tout mélangé fait
qu'il ya plus de joueurs forts en russie
renault en russie preuve des chats qui
peut vraiment gagner 90 mille roubles
situe stud débrouille pas mal et
streamer d'échec c'est une bonne
situation
oui et non je sais pas c'est dur à dire
ça dépend si ça te plaît vraiment ou pas
ça me plaît vraiment oui mais en fait si
tu remettait ça en rapport de combien je
gagne à l'heure ce serait une très
mauvaise situation mais mais après comme
c'est une passion et que du coup si je
le ressens pas comme du travail c'est
une très bonne situation
ça dépend si tu es passionné par le truc
ou pas en fait pour un ordi mais qui
s'en sort un peu mieux avant l'ouverture
que tout à l'heure pendant qu'on parle
d'échec en russie voilà le parti
communiste qui a beaucoup insisté à
jouer aux échecs en russie mais ça ça
remonte même à avant en fait
ouais c'est comme chef de cuisine y va
quand même j'ai comme visite à leur moi
j'ai chopé un chopin petits problèmes de
santé l'a pas ce que je fais beaucoup
trop d'heures va falloir que je fasse
gaffe là pendant quelques semaines à me
limiter mais je vais limiter les vidéos
youtube en fait tu twittes j'aime trop
youtube c'est relou mais mais du coup à
disons que quand tu dépasse
régulièrement les 50 60 heures semaine
au bout d'un moment ça peut se payer
malheureusement
on a beaucoup morose évident streamé ces
temps-ci nom se passe pas un truc grave
à rolf m mais juste ce qu'il faut que je
fasse attention
non je fais la large 50 76 heures de
boulot par semaine où est l'argent
facile et encore je compte pas quand je
réfléchis au boulot hors des heures où
je travaille on y apprend des cas de
prendre des 4 ouais bon ça va être égal
il va récupérer des cats est symétrique
alors
alors il récupère pas le pion direct
parce qu'ils y de compte surtout huit
cavaliers eu deux messi joue cavalier
fera avec les blancs il peut se
retrouver dans la merde banques
pas trop ce qui fait en fait abdou j'ai
l'impression qu'ils craquent en fait
juste il veut jouer tactique et non mais
c'est il va perdre en fait il a craqué
mentalement la partie tout à l'heure où
il a eu un manque de réussite qui a
coûté très cher dans la tête donc
après il y aurait il y aurait pu
échanger en d4 en fait et il est rentré
dans ce truc et il a juste pions des
canons mais là c'est du craquage c'est
juste un craquage la savait si je trouve
le format trop long quand même ouais
franchement je me faisais la relation de
ces ça me réussit à l'heure parce
qu'avant le match je regardais le début
de la finale djoko schwartzmann la
finale de rome et je me disais si le
format du match c'est trois heures
trente de match et ont compté les points
les uns après les autres je pense que
j'aurais jamais je me serais jamais
intéressé au tennis en fait je me serais
dit ce sport n'a aucun intérêt et je me
faisais ça par rapport aux échecs en
fait et je me disais c'est vrai qu'en
vrai le format enfin les formats des
tourrades échec nous coûte tellement
cher
ils sont toujours tellement
systématiquement mauvais que même sur
des sports très regardé le le le même
format serait utilisé ça coûterait très
cher aux sports qui tomberait dans les
oubliettes après quelques années à mon
avis je pense que tu ferais d'un format
comme celui du speech est pour les
tournois de tennis le tennis deviendrait
un sport secondaire en trois quatre ans
mais réellement je dis même pas ça en
trop lent enfin je me suis vraiment fait
la réflexion tout à l'heure en regardant
le match j'ai réfléchi à ça ouais genre
lutèce tennis mais du test et nice les
matchs durent une heure ou que vous quoi
ils durent pas très longtemps
imagine des matchs du test et nice de
3h30 je sens est injuste 3h30 comme ça
quoi
parce que la lutte est aussi fondé ils
font des petits sets quoi mais oui oui
c'est exactement cette chasse est logé
j'ai pensé ça préjudice était peut-être
un peu technique pour le chat
mais je suis le format 8 aces en 3h30 en
fait tu peux tuer le tennis en quelques
mois tirées année c'est marrant quand
même de se dire que on a des formes a
tellement mauvais que qui pourrait tuer
un autre sport en fête qui est déjà très
populaire
je trouve ça intéressant de se poser la
question
philosophiquement
hélas hélas la boue qui va déjà à perdre
et finalement le match qui risque
il ya eu un tilt la part d'abu qui est
moins fort finalement alors là faut
faire garde de ne pas faire damas damas
huit tours c'est lui qui a tout
reprendre cette quand même quand même
pas de piège
allez on va espérer abdullah 4 secondes
contre 20
le baseball après c'est un sport un peu
spécial mais c'est un sport comme ça
c'est pas dix mille donc mais qui est
des quatre fils qui avale et à deux
tours âge 6,3 g 8 ont g6 ça va être fini
bien jouer le petit orage 6 pour
regagner un peu du temps qu'ils essaient
inquiets prend b3 mais les pions vont
plus vite côté blanc allaient tour à 7
c'est bien joué à quatre mais le
cavalier va venir en a trois éteindre
les espoirs douché les espoirs ouzbek à
la tour en d5 très bien placé par
rapport aux cavale qui bloque les cases
de repli et maintenant les pions qui
partent et là ils menacent f4 matt
cavaliers c5 allez faut tenter mais il
est au retour j'ai six mâts de toute
façon aussi c'est pour tenter cave a
lieu quatre abdou qui a craqué dans la
tête et la côté connexion il faut pas
relâcher l'étreinte 1 il faut vraiment
essayer de avant la pause la dent m dos
remettre une pour mettre cinq points
d'écart et tuer le match
trop trop tamba après ouais trop tendre
dans la tête il sait pas il est un peu
moins bien dans les ouvertures non mais
c'est vrai que quand tu défends des
poubelles que est non non mais un peu
temps là encore est pour ça qu il a plus
de facilité en title tune faisait en
format suisse parce qu'il se fait moins
visés dans les ouvertures et xiang il
est américain il se moulent le score
après c'est vera sur le contenu mais
c'est parce qu'il a craqué 1
il a craqué son slip
il a quatre ans manque son adversaire
oui oui mais après ça veut pas dire
qu'il ne ratera pas pour autant ouais le
cip le site n'a pas tenu ce type jaune
devant marron derrière pour pour
jefferies pour nos dires bec mais
peut-être quatre et demi deux ans et
demi c'était le score logique après
ouais ce n'est pas beaucoup mieux mais
ça doit être le score logique mais là
c'est comme un gros craquage je peux
avoir repris le plan des 4
bon
il ya une petite position sympa avec les
blancs là à jouer peut avoir des a5 qui
avait b6 des tours un fouet 3
disons que j'avais battu d'ailleurs la
faute j'avais fait top 5 dans le dans le
title tuesday j'avais battu rond 9 avec
une robe guillon qui avaient subi le
courroux de la grob
et oui il avait lui aussi perdu face à
ma grob
je pense surtout à 3.7 cavaliers des
quatre noms des quatre coups qui est
prendre cinq épreuves trois d'affilée le
pion et s'activer je pense peut-être des
tours 8 ans parlons hockey et des quatre
fois f5
enfin ça ma grosse ground y maintient
des usagers peut-être parler mais tu
penses quoi utilisions duboc landes en
compétition certains trouvent ça pas
qu'on vienne a voté à pauline avis là
dessus bah si tu veux c'est un peu comme
comme cracher sur quelqu'un en ufc moi
j'attends qu'ils carbou face à contre
karpatchev quoi en réel et puis on verra
en fait si c'est si bien que ça de le
faire ou pas on en reparlera après il
n'ya pas fou france et quatre
intermédiaires attaque attaque afin et
surtout prend bessette tourbe et 8
bah oui non mais il voit juste plus rien
à il veut tout rêve d un pardon tu en
prends d un tour prend d un bien joué
non mais qui va ça contre karpatchev 1
on verra enfin peut-être que ça va être
très marrant ou quoi peut-être que non
enfin on ne sait pas en fait non mais vu
sa stature et vu l'importance des toits
qui joue s'est passé en l'équivalent de
cracher à la gueule de quelqu'un en fait
mais je pense que juste faire tout
reprendre et on prend des 1 et j'ai six
ou h6 pour pas avoir deux tours des six
attaques lecavalier fouet f3 tour prend
b2
ça ira pour les poulets pour les blancs
et les noirs
donc
non mais c'est dommage qu'ils car oui
parce que ça dans des parties quand ça
joue plus pour le classement quand c'est
fini en fait à la rigueur qu'ils fassent
ça dans des parties hyper importante
ça me dérangerait mois mais en fait il
se fout de la gueule des gars quand en
fait dans le ton il assuré d'avoir sa
place qui joue plus la gagne qu'il est
3e assuré il peut ni finir derrière ni
de vent et il se met à faire des
ouvertures de merde pour cracher à la
gueule des gens c'est ça en fait qui
m'embête qu'ils le fassent ronde un rond
de 3,35 qu'ils le fassent tout le temps
ça ne dérangerait pas le moins du monde
en fait ils assument mais là en fait
c'est faire des trucs salle sans
l'assumer en fait et ça je trouve que
c'est dommage tu as mois la grotte
contre ma news j'ai joué dans une partie
père importante
en fait je les fais ronde 9 du title
tuesday quand on joue la première place
on était premiers ex-aequo avec manu je
lui ai sorti une robe j'ai fait ça dans
une partie en jeu là il fait ça quand il
peut plus fille peut plus finir deuxième
il peut plus finir 4e il est sûr de
finir troisième et ils t'envoient des
hits en voit des trucs comme ça
ben non mais je sais pas on voit le en
prochaine finale du magnus tour contre
magnus partie 2 quoi pas agir qu'ils le
fassent dans des parties où ça compte
mais en fait il le fait juste dans des
tournois où il sue de la gueule des gars
sans que ça compte
je trouve ça un peu dommage perso enfin
je trouve que c'est pas fait à bon
escient en fait c'est vouloir cracher à
la gueule des gens mais sans l'assumer
quoi en quelque sorte
bah ouais maxime lagarde qui a fait
cavalier à 3 qui avait les âges seront
ils là il a assumé il s'est fait
éliminer il n'a pas fait ça dans une
partie où il jouer la qualif ou quoi tu
vois
pas le public trouve trouve ça sympa
parce que parce que parce que le public
le public est sous influence depuis que
ne réfléchit pas par lui-même il pas b3
pour leur nom ils avaient jamais le
temps de le faire malheureusement il
tout reprend bessette et 30 quand même
nom mais en fait du coup oui je suis pas
contre qu'il le fasse mais qu'il le
fasse dans des partis qui comptent quoi
c'est tout sinon c'est moche
si la dent le speech s il fait fou le
boom claude et qui se fait éliminer par
par guillon que je serais pas contre
quoi si la partie n'a plus d'intérêt
sortir une petite ouverture marrante ça
redonne intérêts il ya une différence
overflow entre une ouverture marrante et
une ouverture où tu veux battre le mec
en se foutant de sa gueule en fait ces
deux choses différentes
ces deux choses très différentes
tu pourrais jouer un gambit un peu
marrant une ouverture jérôme un gambit
jérôme genre de truc ou un gambit
halloween au genre de truc où tu
attaques t'envoie et puis c'est
différent le banc claude c'est vraiment
du cracher à la gueule quoi mais bon
après c'est mon opinion fait ce qu'il
veut je m'en fous complètement si les
gens aiment bien et que ça leur plaît
c'est tant mieux
il a fait contre lyon que justement la
grotte c'est une ouverture juste perdant
de gwent surtout manque légende on a
analysé encore plus
suite à la petite hype qui a eu ce comme
servir à la cuillère ouais mais c'est
pire que servir à la cuillère quand tu
mènes 6 0 5 0
c'est cette humaine 6 0 5 0 40 0 tu fait
trois double fautes et après tu sers à
la cuillère mais genre trois double
fautes ou tu fais exprès mais je suis
pas content que tu fasses ça m'est fait
le dès le premier jeu
tu es un troll à ce qu'on dit mais tu
joues pas le black mardi moeurs de la
corniche juste une mauvaise couverture
en fait ouais le chrono est fini mais
pour c'est 1h30 la safer nul en sept
finales du mr x ou y j'imagine mais je
reçois du gabut jany je veux écoute
jouable en fait tout est jouable ouais
kyi et dé 5,6
espace coiffure calice et 7,6 à turin à
tour ses cinq pour ces 4 c'était bien vu
un mec avaya 4 bien vu ils menacent tour
b1 et cavaliers prend certes il faut
faire tomber 5 mai attend également un
pion de plus pour les blancs il va faire
tour à quatre et il va réseauter le roi
est attaqué à 5 en même temps alors
attends il n'y a pas de vrai ok mais n'y
a pas de match ce qui à foot 2 il y
apparaît je pensais qu'il y avait un qui
avait lieu deux cavaliers quelque chose
mais avec tours f5 ils empêchent les
retours à f4 pour faire a minima nul
donc énoncé bien joué il n'ya pas tourbe
et un fouet f1 qu'avait lieu de roy g2
3e 6
c'est ce qui va se passer je pense
il fait cavalier aussi serait maintenant
il ya six tours à 5
donc il faut faire tour un airois g2 et
c'est plutôt bien si l'action gas c'est
hyper bien joué c'est encore moi j'ai
trois qui éprouve ses deux et il va
peut-être falloir mettre tourbe et sept
fous j'ai deux voyous tour b6 j'aime
bien parce que le roi où il va s'il va
sur la 7ème ses coups gratuits
je fais tourbe et cinq échecs ça je m'y
attendais pas assez bien joué ça parce
que maintenant quand on fait non tourbez
set mais s'est tout juste bon je sais
pas
en tout cas avec les blancs ils
s'emmêler les pinceaux il a refilé un
lion il en était probablement pas obligé
c'est une partie compliquée mais où je
pense qu'il ya quelques fautes
d'un côté de l'autre avant la partie est
vraiment est vraiment complexe on sent
qu'ils ratent des petits trucs
l'un et l'autre mais y en a tellement et
c'est quand même vision qui est au
dessus des débats
il doit il est un peu plus fort dans
tous les compartiments du jeu ce soir
si lyon gagne cette partie je pense que
le match est plié
on continue à espérer un petit
retournement de situation tour g iii
doit faire nul ici way en cas de nul ici
on va dire qu'il maintient quand même un
petit espoir
disons qu'il veut quand même la gagner
il est insupportable y lâche rien le
joueur américain
malgré le peu de temps est mais là cette
fois ci va faire nul et il a bien raison
jefferies qui tourne qui tourne à plus 4
qui tourne à plus quatre gros écart
ouais gros écart 4 points mais bon ça
peut se remonter finalement abdou qui
qui s'en tirent way qui s'en tirent pas
très bien quand même un en vue du match
mais mes quatre points la dernière il
était pas si bien il a réussi à arrêter
le l'hémorragie va avoir cinq minutes de
pause ils vont changer de cadence
ouais il peut il peut revenir
graduellement dans le match encore à 4
points tu peut encore revenir
graduellement essayé sur les 60
prochaines nuits de reprendre deux
points et de finir en force en bullet
mais je trouve que que guillon quand
même a vraiment pris le dessus dans les
ouvertures et même dans le petit jeu
tactique on le sent maintenant un peu au
dessus après la dynamique du match peut
encore changer un c'est pas c'est pas
gravé dans la roche encore la différence
et pas si importante à différences
intrinsèques entre les deux n'est
peut-être pas non plus donc à d'où
peut-être
revenir par contre si enfin le moindre
break l'adoption que tu le match c'est à
dire que là il est qu à 4,5 points c'est
l'écart maximum en fait quand tu passes
à six points c'est impossible de revenir
quasi donc c'est du 99,5 ou 99,9 de
victoire donc là on va dire qu'il au
dernier vrai 4 5 points ce sera le
maximum a pressé ses morts donc il
faudra qu'ils reviennent très en forme
abdou pour pour le début de la prochaine
cadence moi je vais faire une petite
pause je vous remette la dernière partie
en replay une petite pub et et on se
retrouve dans cinq petites minutes pour
pour la suite les gars on se retrouve
dans un peu de cinq petites minutes pour
la suite en espérant un petit peu de
suspense à un retour d'abdou dans le
match
je suis de retour tout le monde pour ce
surnom passionnant non mais c'est un
match sympa mais après c'est vrai que
c'est vraiment trop long enfin je sais
pas je le dis à chaque fois mais mais
parce que c'est vrai en fait c'est
réellement trop long ça et quand quand
tu y penses à chaque fois ces quatre
heures c'est énorme en fait c'est énorme
quatre heures c'est énorme c'est
vraiment un truc de ouf quand ils
pensent je connais réellement il ya
réellement très très peu de compétition
qui ont des formats comme ça c'est
beaucoup trop long
à chaque fois j'y pense mais fait 1h30
c'est bien mais là le fait qu'ils aient
encore en comptant les pauses 1h45 1h50
sais je ne peux pas comprendre ça fait 3
heures de trop non pour moi entre un
spectacle centre 75 minutes et 120
minutes en général
ça met vraiment en pls jeu mais le truc
c'est que ça va continuer comme ça il
n'y aura pas de changement la saison
prochaine ou qu avant j'avais de
l'espoir que ça change maintenant j'en
ai plus ça continuerait à être comme ça
pour pour l'éternité en fait non entre
entre 1h15 et deux heures c'est bien ça
à peu près ce qu'il faut
ça à peu près ce qu'il faut je sais pas
si tu peux en parler en étant émergents
la chine est ce que tu aimes a prévu un
programme de la semaine dans la semaine
sur lui ce riz bosse à peu près toujours
pareil ça dépend surtout des richesses
souvent mais sinon c'est à peu près
pareil c'est le title cuisse dès le le
mardi les master class le mercredi c'est
à peu près la même chose tout le temps
c'est toujours à peu près la même chose
ap le chrono qui est reparti
c'est reparti alors là ça a vite vite
c'est donc j'en mettais le chrono oui ok
ça à rejouer à mais tout à l'heure je
vois que c'est avec les blancs qu'on
était rentré dans les espagnols côté
abdou ça c'est la variante donc j'ai
parlé il n'y a pas très longtemps dans
la partie ii mvl contre et imane ceux
qui ont suivi
et donc voilà je suis retourné sur le
direct en passant rapidement on arrivait
dans cette finale qui a un peu plus
sympa jouait pour les blancs parce
qu'ils ont un avantage des espaces et le
roi qui est déjà centralisée mais après
ça doit aller pour les noirs un roi et
fuit trois sets et je vois pas pourquoi
les noirs seraient moins bien non plus
il n'y a pas de cette bataille prévues
cette semaine on met ça battle je veux
pas trop en faire non plus hein je
souhaite pas faire trop de ce battle non
plus
c'est une bonne idée de mettre tous les
pions sur case blanche là on fait le
cavalier il tient bien la chaîne parce
qu'il tient bessette assiste donc de
toutes façons les pions non pas se faire
attaquer il tient à 4 pour les ruptures
donc en fait c'est la construction soit
qui est bonne après il faut pas se
prendre tour c'est un b3 quoi mais
normalement tu vas pas te le prendre
il peut faire pousser 6 avec les blancs
pour essayer de forcer tour ait fuité
bloquer l'arrivée du roi à manquer a dit
stop aux abattages vrai nom mais va
peut-être falloir un jour qu'on fasse
les ce battle en optimisant notre équipe
bon allons peut-être faire nul ici c'est
une proposition tacite de nuls puisque
tours 8 pour le roi et filles c'est
assez logique
il revient en c6 et ils font nul bon
c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour
abdou parce qu'enfin pour une fois ils
souffrent plus dans l'ouverture avec les
noirs et donc il peut essayer de
construire là dessus il peut essayer de
construire là dessus donc il retourne
dans l'arceau limo mais il a encore il
change de variantes
mais tu veux faire l'essuie pédagogique
avec charpentier donc savait pas très
bien marché il se moulant vrai et puis
là en plus c'est difficile avec l'emploi
du temps à le mettre en place
donc on verra plus tard ouais il faut
qu'ils essayent de revenir dans l'ordre
de 3 + 1 exactement
j'imagine qu'il va faire f 4g 6,70 f5 un
peu dans le même esprit que ce qu'il
avait fait tout à l'heure sur fou j'ai
cette île af six ans plus sûrement
il tente et de flyers ils étaient loin
de pouvoir flag et abdou dans la partie
précédente où tu as encore une minute et
quelques kg 7 et peut-être 6
à faire cavalier russie si on prend 1,7
qui haïssez trois fous ou trois dames
des deux est envoyée on va voir mais f6
peut-être cavale peut-être qu'avec sept
pions trompions prend et qui a valu aux
six pour essayer de récupérer sac et ses
3 way dame prend l homme pressé qui les
prend des cinq encore c'est hyper
compliqué à la position là en fait tu
fais pas et fils tu fais quoi
ce que si tu prends y prend il va faire
réussissent damage 4000 fait foi h3 et
sur cavani f5 après fils je n'ai pas
forcément envie non plus un mais jusqu'à
9,5 je comprends pas en fait à y veut
peut-être fou prend pions prend 1,6 à
aimer action prend tout reprend mais roy
je suis pas convaincu de ce truc là
mais après c'est compliqué il ya
peut-être d'autres idées
ouais on va voir parce que ouais prise
prise mais aussi ça a pas suffi reims et
sur d'anne decis or sur damage 5 il veut
grand roque ça c'est sûr et sur pions
prend f7 il veut roi prend damage cinq
dames g6 c'est hyper malin d'anne decis
ouais c'est hyper malin il reprend tempo
il va pouvoir blindé le truc avec 6 tôt
ou tard
fawcett pour g8 sur die frage cet échec
c'est quoi le bail afu g7 juste et
tourache 8 d'accor et c3 il a pris des
quatre fous et royaliste ces deux
accueils cedria dame f5 dame prend à des
médecins qui a damé fz6 la fouine dame
ces deux dames f3 matt aut s'est très
bien joué mais très mal joué de la part
d'abdul s'auto raffin parce que ça se
voit de loin que c'est mauvais ça fait
des grimaces ken jeong là mais ça a
l'air de fonctionner son truc mais là
d'où il envoie il envoie il en voit trop
en fait poussé 5,6 à la tête d'un truc
qui pourra jamais marcher il veut dame
français cinq dames pro f 5 bat mais bon
mamad mettons roigé cette dame français
de la maison c'est c'est quand même un
pion de plus pour les noirs etc les
noirs qui ont plus d'attaquants fait
d'un f4 et l'autre tentative alors
maintenant son idée sur notre dame
france est fou j'ai 7 11 7
fait qu'il valait des cinq dames g4 mais
ça va échanger et il reste le problème
des tours et sur carhaix lieu 3 ça il a
raté mais il accueille prend 20 qui
étrangers quatre cavaliers des 3ème et
en plus il a la réussite assez terrible
c'est terrible pour abdou mais bon le
problème c'est qu'il ya tellement des
positions de merde
il a tellement des positions pourri en
fait que ça peut pas aller il y aura
toujours un truc même si on ne l'avait
pas vu parce que là c'est clair c'est
via la caméra qu'il avait pas vu mais
même s'il a pas vus en fait c'est pas
important
il y aura toujours un truc c'est trop
mauvais en fait ce qu'il fait là il a
juste craqué mentalement il est plus
dans la ccl fini 1 mais exige un gain
impressionnant un nom c'est mort je
pense
je pense vraiment que c'est game 1 ouais
c'est dur c'est dur pour abdou mais
après il est derrière il est derrière il
est derrière clairement autant sur la
première is moule où j'ai dit qu'il
n'avait pas de chance il a vraiment pas
eu de bol parce que parce que jong
fallait plusieurs variantes et ils se
sauvent vraiment in extremis autant dans
celle là
en vrai il est tellement mal qui aura
tout il y aura toujours une tactique qui
sauvera ton adversaire en fait c'est que
quoi que tu fasses en fait y aura
toujours un truc que tu as oublié
jeffrey xiang s'est pas l'épicier du
coin
il y aura toujours un problème
annoncé à
malheureusement pour l'intérêt du match
c'est un peu un peu de chemin parce
qu'il reste encore une heure et demie à
regarder et là avec un tel écart
à moins d'une remontée la date du 7 au
rove qui remonteraient à -3 ou moins
quatre dans le 3 + 1 ce qui est encore
possible mais même là ce serait dur mais
sinon l'intérêt du match et quand même
très réduit 1
je suis d'accord il soul des foyers
tactique qui sauf que t'as pas vu mais
là ils étaient ils étaient trop mal
toulon en fait
abdou même là ils rejouent de manière
active mais de nouveau il va avoir mis
way il se fait prendre dans l'ouverture
il se fait prendre par tout cas du
sahara nascimento je crois que c'est
sarah d'un enfin le jus de chaque bit
fait puisque le match me semblait jouée
d'avancé sarhane à mon avis sera explosé
par n'importe quel joueur au tour
prochain mais bon on verra je peux me
tromper claque zhiyong qui sort le gros
match et abdou satarov un peu un peu
décevant 1
un peu décevant d'avoir balancé comme ça
pour elle et pas fort en beat ci
viennent cauet mais ça rana est plus
fort classé dommage sermat je suis là si
affiché de belles promesses sur le
papier et finalement qui nous les a
donné parce que nous a offert des belles
parties après gérer c'est plus le format
qui tue le match que le match en soi
parce que en gros si on avait eu un
format 7 la soirée fut de 2 sets 0 le
match se sera arrêtée maintenant après
deux heures de jeu sort et et ça aurait
été bien il ya beaucoup de nuls il ya eu
un premier set très serré
puis après un deuxième set qui tourne
complètement al'avantage de giang
j'ai envie de dire au mental et ça peut
ça paraîtrait une belle histoire souvent
le format qui tue le match choisi dare
dare adbul le sens où je le répète trop
souvent tu as peut être raison mais
après c'est le cas c'est difficile de
faire abstraction de pas dans le sens
c'est le car oui c'est c'est difficile
de faire abstraction de ce problème qui
fait que l'on est déjà ô combien de
matchs on fait dans ce type là mais
peut-être au 125e match déjà qui à cause
du format un intérêt quand même assez
réduit c'est dommage
c'est dommage
explique pour s'endormir et alors là il
va être obligé de faire tourner huit
dames 1
pour celui d'amiens je pense sinon la
dame est enfermé je crois que sa seule
manière de s'en sortir
aïe à tour cédé 1 aussi pardon à les
labos qui a joué un peu plus vite
fait autour d un salon il peut peut-être
là gagnable d'où il doit sentir la il
est mieux au temps pour une fois
vacances a pu jouer surtout à ce point
comme ça fait 3 + 0 et spylo à nash en
tout cas à partir d'un certain niveau
mais ça lui sitemap 22 geffray qui
propose nul
hu est acceptée il à nouveau les blancs
et ils passent à des quatre maintenant
abdou je veux petit truc solides avec
des 4,3 kf3 x 2 qu'on appelle le trois
poisons
déjà par off qui était un excellent
sprinteur qui a dû gagner de plusieurs
reprises le maillot vert j'imagine sur
le tour de france
bon ça développe et peut-être faire
[ __ ] 3 ou 4 3 3 qui est joué mais
peut-être échanger et faire dame f32
pourquoi pas c'est solina
je suis inquiet très énervé du match
chiens qui aboient y avait eu quatre
prises prise il peut prendre un f6 en
premier il va reprendre leucate échanges
en f3 mais bon là encore moi j'aime pas
trop jouer ces trucs là avec les noirs
mais en vrai c'est tout à fait correct 1
ça ressemble de nouveau à une structure
gambie dame
torcéen sa tête échanger faire les pions
pendant les pions baki
damas est en position assez égal de
nouveau hommage bien les noirs même
finalement puisque ce avec le fou g7
il attaque le pion des cats le fouet de
à la défense ces 5 va être dur à jouer
essai de vaud plutôt guillon qui prend
le dessus alors il a réussi encore à le
faire à cause de bébé prend dame prend
cac et prend des 5 grâce parce qu'il
faut calculer cb prend prisé qui avait
lieu 4 qui est l'option pour mettre la
pression sur tout un
c'est la partie d'ailleurs
sur cavalli prend 4 tu en prends 1 4
peut-être dame eu deux prises b2 prises
des deux prises d emprise d un prix c5
ce genre de choses donc il a fait des
quatre tours b 8 à 3 il veut à 5 et met
la pression le long de la colonne b
là c'est dangereux honnêtement si
abdullah percer là je pense que le match
est vraiment terminée une bonne fois
pour toutes à c'est bien ou pas bien les
pions pendant ça dépend de la position
ça dépend du placement de pièces autour
mais là c'est plus des pions pendant
déjà il a encore faim et n'ont plus
jamais vraiment eu de pions pendant
qu'ils éprouvent 4 fou prend b2 il veut
quoi là dessus car ali hafsi c'est sur
roy g7 car les jets 4
d'accord il veut sur foot français à
avoir damev 6 et cavaliers h 6 mais là
encore c'est un truc ultra risque n ya
rien de tout reprend b4 déjà rien que
tout reprend bay 4-1 qui devra retourner
un tour prend b2 damev 6 mais bon h5
maintenant tour prend b2 et prix g4 non
mais en fait ça va
ae prix gigaton madame dame madame c3
bon ok mais ça paraît superficiel ce qui
fait quand même à chaque fois il se
lance dans des trucs dans la chance de
réussite est quand même très faible sur
f5 je pense qu'il veut tour prend b2 sur
pions pranger cas dont il adams et 3 est
prise là et surtout reprend je pense
qu'ils misent sur le fait d'attaquer sur
la colonne b donc quitte à faire ça
serait plutôt le faire avec h 5000 fait
autour des v8 qui est le coup logicom sa
surprise prise échec il ya plus b2 en
l'air mais je trouve qu'à douce au top
se lance vraiment dans des variantes
voué à l'échec en fait il peut en sauver
quelques unes mais sur le long terme tu
peux pas jouer un match comme ça il faut
absolument [ __ ] le bordel way abdou et
xiang il attend juste et y réfute
alors il faut pouvoir le faire hein
c'est très difficile de réfuter à face à
des joueurs de ce niveau là mais comme
il en a la qualité
il vit fait faillir et fut tout
simplement les les erreurs adverses et
c'est tout ce qui va tenter roi des sept
rois 17 cavaliers st croix c'est cette
dame f6 c'est hyper dangereux quand tu
auras un problème avec afs est qui est
dur à défendre il peut tenter roi 17 car
l ie 5 3 au 7 mai accueilli ces six
skippers avaient intérêt à prendre là
nul et c'est ce qu'il a fait et il
reprend les blancs non mais il gère son
match il a cinq points d'avance il reste
il reste que que 35 minutes dans la
cadence y gère et puis veut il veut
faire enfler le score petit à petit la
pas besoin de prendre de risques surtout
que je pense que même si le score était
égal servent à rien de risqué ça ça
semble être le genre de positions plus
simple à jouer pour les blancs
ouais c'est nouveau cette petite à
cambridge spring un très très théorique
et abdou qui continue à souffrir un mois
ça une position qu'ils jouent mais mais
c'est un peu moins bien à long terme est
à cinq points de retard et ce qu'il a
gagné une partie d'ailleurs ce que nous
d'habitude on met le score avec les
victoires des esclaves d'où on a gagné
une
et je crois pas un qu'il a encore gagné
une partie
ça me revient pas c'est pour ça que
d'habitude mais les scores avec les
victoires pour savoir qui a gagné
combien de partis mais à cinq points de
retard et on n'a toujours pas gagné une
ça paraît calme compliqué
priez très solide
je crois qu'il a fait s'est tenue les 7
nuls et 5 défaites ouais je crois bien
ouais on c'est terrible c'est pour ça
qu'on voit pas du tout dans quel monde
ils remontent 1
et zéro victoire ça fait quand même mal
quand à cinq points de retard après en
bullet c'est quoi le classement des
joueurs en bullet 3088 pour mme jiang
2832 pour ouais non mais c'est game mon
frère je sais même pas ce qu'on regarde
là c'est game j'ai voulu miser sur la
surprise j'étais chaud et finalement
comme d'hab le favori qui gagne
je suis ok c'est aujourd'hui la surprise
mais non ouais c'est lé favori qui gagne
vraiment à chaque fois un ces matches il
ya vraiment jamais de surprise même si
je m'étais chauffer va essayer de dire
oui abdou et grand favori et où mais non
voilà le truc c'est que les noirs sont
complètement fermés alors apprête à la
paire de fous tu tiens bien tu es solide
mais fort avant qu'ils recommencent à
gagner des game 1
après le match aura une période quand
même assez sympa je dirais jusqu'à 1h20
1h30 de jeu c'était cool après là c'est
devenu 3 à sens unique mais ça mais ça
après c'est une question de format c'est
pas ça vient pas des joueurs il y
peuvent rien en fait
ces freins combien
séance et entend mdd il ya trois heures
trente de jeu avec des pauses ya quatre
heures de match en gros fail à trois
heures de jeu et ça fait 3 heures 30
avec les pose un peu plus ouais il ya eu
des belles games au début mai
pressez pas grave c'est comme ça juste
le truc ainsi qui est un peu dommage ça
décourage un peu tu la compétition après
ce week-end à la prod chasse ligue qui
se jouera par internet du coup alors là
encore un ça va être hyper long je
préfère vous prévenir les deux live
samedi et dimanche je j'ai lu des
informations contradictoires mais mais
il prévoit en fait y aura six heures les
demi-finales et 6h match pour la 3e
place et finale mais donc on soutiendra
à fond l'équipe d'arménie bien
évidemment et ce que je lui dise après
après il y aura les parties pédagogique
avec seb mazet hcr cas
une autre ce week-end la prod chez sig
avec avec évidemment l'équipe d'arménie
sa crise de pièces pour abdou mais bon
il fait n'importe quoi en fait
mais on compte sur l'arménie on espère
qu'ils remportent la compétition
et demain on le taille touch sera
excellent blog ici c'est pas mal joué ce
qui fait la france et ça me prend des
cas fait il rend une qualité mais pour
se faciliter la vie
jefferies gens resteront au sein qui le
disent au revoir cavaliers 2,4 et il
commence à être tentaculaire avec les
cavaliers
c'est la partie d'ailleurs
non mais j'aimerais bien qu'on dise pas
de mal de l'équipe d'arménie dans le
chatt attention parce que moi je serai
très ferme en supporters des arméniens
ce week end
donc je sais viré par des banh le
premier qui met en doute les
performances de l'équipe d'arménie subir
à mon courroux attention attention je
vais sévir tête dam des quatre ici avait
dam des catins mère d'accueil g5 et bien
calculer quand même ce que ça donne
quand même envie de se remettre les
pions pourquoi aurais-je pour l'arménie
j'ai le droit
il a raté dame prend 1,6 alors la
position est compliqué mais si zoug la
gagne celle là ça va faire mal
il a raté cas et des six qui gagne la
dame en 1 quand même c'est pas de chance
moi j'ai une petite ordi après mais
quand même c'est des grosses erreurs là
y'a pas tomber cette racaille et g5
là il a perdu les deux pions abdou est
mise à part grosse gaffe ou missclick ça
va être fini le score qui continue à
enfler ça va faire plus six arrêtés le
arrêté jeffrey xiong les amis il n'y a
plus de match la plus si c'est le
exactement le score que je vous disais
au moment où normalement on est sûr
voilà 999 chance sur mille que ce soit
fini
non mais faites très attention et vos
petites allusions sur l'équipe d'arménie
je serai à fond pour l'équipe d'arménie
j'espère que ce sera de nouveau la
grande surprise de la compétition bat
bon là il n'y a plus de match j'ai pas
eu et que vous commente les parties ou
quand on discute avec le chat parce que
honnêtement l'intérêt du match vient de
baisser en flèche la déjà accepté
c'était pas top il fait quand même pas
mal de grimaces il a des grimaces
bizarre d'ailleurs non pas par un pro il
grimace qui doit saisir puis on prend
qui ont prende à me prendre
qu'est-ce qu'il fait grimacer c'est là
du calcul est fou et 6
y'a pas tour ses cinq as fou prend ses
500 récupère la pièce pas il doit
connaître en fait cette grimace qui se
rappelle pas d'un truc l'inversé il a
une grille il fait une grimace de temps
en temps qui est hyper bizarre en fait
je suis à fond pour l'arménie
j'ai le droit quand même nom mais je les
sens je les sens fort c'est c'est une
belle équipe et qui eux qui voient là et
toujours et toujours outsider et qu'il
ya une quasiment tous ses matches j'aime
bien quand ils ont un bel esprit
d'équipé
ça donne envie de les supporter alors ah
oui ok la différence c'est que sur fouet
si sa ket et des six maintenant
alors calvetta nous sort une information
comme importante ce parti indique que
l'un des deux médecins l'équipe sarr
qassam ce site et le kinésithérapeute
sont en garde à vue n'a hero queen tana
et son frère d'ailleurs ont été
auditionnés dans la journée vu comment
ils sont nul ce serait quand même bête
de s'être dopé quoi en tout cas si eux
étaient dopés que faisait les autres
parce que c'est pas l'équipe qui nous a
impressionnés un soyons honnête je sais
même pas s'ils ont gagné une étape non
pas non mais il était complètement nul
tout le monde enfin arkéa samsic à part
envoyé dégâts dans les échappées pour
montrer le maillot ça pas fait grand
chose hein
deux pages est souvent là pour tenter de
pallier un manque de performance avala
saharien palier du tout un mec n'avait
ce qu'ils ont pesé sur la course en une
seule étape en fait
ah oui ils font parler d'eux pour le
dopage
ah ça c'est parfois tard thunder
bon c'est trois je pense qu'il va plus
se tourner vers le dopage mécanique en
fait que le dopage
enfin après c'est un point de vue un
mail et petit moteur dans le vélo ça m'a
l'air d'être moins risqué enfin à une
époque
or il a raté sa a maintenant il a rien
rater du tout il avait raté mais y'a
tomber un échec assez terrible c'est
terrible il l'avait pas vu zhang
mais après tout reprend aussi à tomber
un an mais ok il est normal moment donné
il a quand même une réussite de ouf bon
abdou est complètement nul ne pas avoir
camatte du couloir à la fin mais c'est
terrible quand même qu'ils ont guy là
encore il n'avait pas vu bon après il
joue mieux et il mérite de gagner
amplement mais en plus il a tout pour
lui mais là abdou quand même pas pas
avoir le mal du couloir c'est quand même
hallucinant
bas mais en plus c'est juste un bon
direct ses qualités de - non mais là en
plus la laque et legs la qualité de jeu
est devenu vraiment famélique 1
dans une prise ils ont qu'à l'âge 16 ans
pourra booth abdou sato rohff et 20 ans
pour jefferies giang
d'accord il veut il veut il veut roi
c'est six fois c'est 3 bessette qui
haïssez 5
5 cette fête si les changes des tours ça
va être simple à gagner c'est pour ça
que les blancs veulent vraiment pas
échanger
t il envoie ses pièces un peu au
casse-pipe la savoie qui calcule pas
vraiment ils envoient les pièces au
casse pipe et malheureusement tout est
menacé et sur qui a et b ci s'il doit y
avoir tout reprend qui a rallié prend
tour à 5
parce que le truc c'est que veut
contre-attaquer mater peut peut-être
faire tout reprend cavaliers prend elle
c'est pas si simple
mon ordinateur affiche moins 7,1 mais
c'est pas si simple il ya tous les coups
qui gagne en fait ces terribles que tout
gagne sauf ça qui n'était pas le plus
précis mais en fait c'est le problème
c'est qu'ils avaient tellement des
poubelles que même si jefferies se
trompent
ça reste gagnant pour lui la et caïds et
8 encore roy monde cavalier e set
ok peut-être phase 3 8/3 17 alors et
qu'il prendrait qu'un des six salles et
il sait faire arnaquer zhang
c'était encore une nouvelle fois
n'importe quoi à côté abdou mais cette
fois ci s'est passé mais ça reste
avantage noir parce qu'ils ont les
plombs passé lié il va essayer de la
gagner en faisant un f5 afca 3 ici
poussé le pion aux 3 il va faire h5 ici
ouais il va faire flamber sais tu vas
mettre le pion e4 il va faire 3 ème et
les deux pions passé lié comme ça ça
gagne il a fait n'importe quoi
abdou haye est énervé à l'écran le voir
la cam jeffrey xiang qui a été lui-même
surpris du du niveau de jeu désespérant
de son adversaire qu'il n'y ait plus un
dans ce match on va quand même encore
pour être bien sûr un rajouter une
petite heure de compétition il soir
d'être bien sûr que le meilleur gagne
si jamais on ne sait pas abouti à babu
c'est pas son style en fait de jeu
offensif comme ça ils s'auto met la
pression pour remonter et il fait
n'importe quoi là sept points c'est
c'était déjà fini à 6 est encore plus
fini à 7
un nouveau match et c'est une nouvelle
déception un côté spectateurs j'ai du
mal à trouver les mots pour vous
commentez ce qu'on est en train de
regarder comme d'hab j'en suis même un
petit peu désolé un jeune moine
personnages phares sur vous faire des
lives sympa et tout est là c'est vrai
qu'on a un peu un profit de pris de
court
difficile 1-2 d'année mais ça
correctement il n'y a rien à dire
il n'a pas répété pour la 50e fois que
ça n'a aucun intérêt que les joueurs
donnent quand même tout ce qu'ils ont
donc je veux surtout pas qu'on leur
jette la pierre mais malheureusement ils
font face à un format comme complexe non
au curling ça arrive pas ce genre de
choses ils ont un système de 2,7 aussi
avec un nombre de points comme à la
pétanque
maintenant qu en ligne plus intéressant
quand il y avait de belles parties au
début ne surgisse coup le match aurait
donné une heure une heure et quart 1h20
entre une heure et une heure et demie ça
aurait été un beau match
une heure et demie on va dire l'aller
les 2h15 en plus son sont de trop
ivan en boxe était ko mais seuls way
équivalent box où tu es jeux il ya peu
d'équivalent en fait ça a commencé il ya
deux heures et demi déjà c'était de
faire
ouais donc une nouvelle fois une petite
deux parties qu'on a déjà eu avec le
peler la structure symétrique au centre
après là les joueurs sont en gestion 1
vous en connaissez des sports 1 v1 ou
sajoo un certain temps et non pas un
certain nombre de points j'en connais
pas pou corps en vrai ça me vient pas à
l'esprit
là tout de suite si je crois que c'est
les échecs c'est vraiment le seul où on
fait ça abdou photographier les ouzbeks
les sports de combat oui mais dans les
sports de combat arts martiaux une
possibilité de chaos qui chassent
ailleurs ce qui change quand même un peu
la dot cercle à y aurait quand même eu
chaos à ce moment là et au judo aussi en
fait c'est du temps mais tata moyens de
faire un ippon et puis c'est pas 3h45
ces cinq minutes français cinq minutes
le judo c'est quand même différent jouer
sur cinq minutes pourquoi pas c'est un
peu comme un blitz et une limite de
temps quoi mais la boxe et la
possibilité du chaos et les matchs sont
quand même plus court ces douze rounds
de trois minutes alors même si une pause
ça fait douze fois 5
ça fait une heure un combat de boxe la
fin c'est pas une limite déjà c'est pas
vraiment un sport individuel
et puis c'est une limite de tours pas de
temps
et quand bien même ce serait du temps
c'est cadré pour durer une heure et
demie et la fin ça peut être très chiant
à moins que ce format là mais ça peut
être très relevé mais c'est vrai que
c'est peut-être pas pour rien qu'il ya
aucun sport au monde qui ait pris ce
format là quand même c'est pas une heure
ça doit pas être une hasard
façon il n'y a pas énormément de gens
qui suivent n'y a pas beaucoup de public
1 pour ces matchs donc ça veut ça tend à
prouver que les gens pensent comme nous
pour la plupart jetons et 430 ce qui est
pas mal en anglais ils sont six mille
neuf cent mais ils ont sûrement une
première page ou quoi mais ce qui est
quand même peu je regardais les autres
langues
je descends un peu en bas au choix un
peu des trucs à côté les gamins désolé
pour ceux qui veulent vraiment commenter
à fond en portugais ils sont 230 en
allemand ils sont 23 en espagne 333 ils
ont peut-être une première page
d'ailleurs aussi en espagnol
généralement ils sont moins
donc oui en fait c'est tu as quand même
très peu de gens qui suivent
dans le carnet 434 25 millions de vior
que tu fais même quand tu veux pas aux
échecs
ah oui bien sûr à 1430 quand moi je fais
n'importe quoi oui 430 on les a cassés
quasiment systématiquement 1
mais oui oui non mais sinon tu enlèves
entre guillemets tout ce que j'ai fait
pour développer un peu le streaming sur
twitter en français je pense qu'à 50
personnes enfin s'est vu que le ratio
français par rapport à espagnol ou
portugais qui sont deux grosses langon
devrait être deux fois moins donc
donc oui on y aurait 50 ou 100 personnes
ouais ouais mais c'est sain tu as
intérêt son père en vrai mais c'est pas
à cause de la fiche parce que l'affiché
vraiment belle aujourd'hui les mecs
autant j'ai eut critiqué des affiches
gu10 certaines affiches qui qui pour moi
valait pas vraiment le coup autant cette
affiche là elle valait vraiment le coup
et là il va se rendre tours 7
hélas tous réussissent encore à il va
peut-être la gagne est allé il ya le
pion des aléas bout pour nous faire
rêver
au moins en gagner une ça va lui faire
du bien
non mais en plus le truc en plus c'est
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai carrément fait un
tweet pour dire que ce sera un beau
match et l'a ratée f4 qui viennent une
pièce plongée lors dix ans pour me dire
les petits coups mais il a raté et je me
suis dit aujourd'hui j'étais vraiment en
mode ça va être un beau match je vais
pas dire que c'est un format de merde et
tout le match va être serré toulon et je
me suis dit ça va ça va le faire et
finalement non
évidemment non et aujourd'hui j'étais
vraiment en mode non aujourd'hui c'est
un beau match je suis ça va ça va
envoyer
j'espérais cap dou prennent le lead dans
le blitz que l'hôte essaye de revenir en
bullet et où je m'étais dit le scénario
peut peut être intéressant parce que je
faire des blitz ce soir bail à mazet qui
va venir faire les parties pédagogique
après je vais pas je vais pas rester
trop tard comme je disais plus tôt
j'étais des petits soucis de santé il
faut que je fasse attention mais ah mais
oui bien sûr on va on va on va faire les
particules à écologique on fera quelques
blitz
j'arrive pas à pas être négatif leila
top ouais j'arrive pas à pas être
objectif en fait
j'arrive pas à un moment donné à me dire
non mais tout va bien en fait comment
quand il ya un truc qui va vraiment pas
et que pour la énième fois j'arrive pas
à me retenir en fait c j'adore être
positif et dire que tout est génial mais
quand c'est vraiment pas le cas je
n'arrive pas à prendre le dessus en fait
surtout quand c'est pas la première fois
ni la 10e ni la 130ème et que c'est le
125e ou 130e match et que c'est toujours
la même la même chose un moment donné
c'est j'ai du mal à à rester à rester
positif
surtout que j'y croyais dans ce match là
allez peut-être abdou qui va me faire
mentir est remonté à jeffrey a laissé
passer quelques occasions dans le
dernier il lève un peu le pied ça peut
lui coûter
ça peut lui coûter
on a besoin de toi capitaine danny
richer pas pourquoi ça lui plaît autant
ce format je sais qu ils l'adorent mais
j'arrive pas à comprendre pourquoi
très franchement je ne sais pas quel est
le
le tour de magie fait qu'il adore ce
format
non je suis pas assez fort pour
participer à ce genre de tournoi xpm ich
tue pas assez fort pour participer à ce
genre de tournoi
c'est un patriote ce matin merci semoule
à qq la paille khris aleka je suis
depuis tes débuts tu n'es même pas mis
la bo je n'interviens pas souvent mais
je passais des bons moments tout
simplement je dis parfois envers moi
tellement de temps consacré à ce jeu
ouais c'est vrai qu'on y passe beaucoup
de temps sur ce jeu mais il est
passionnant il est extraordinaire ce jeu
il nous le rend bien
à partir de ce matin était vraiment
sympa j'ai fait la vidéo hier du coup je
m'étais dit que c'était une vidéo qui
vous une partie qui vous intéresseraient
par ailleurs qui va être facile winamax
à côté ouais vous avez bien raison les
gars il va peut-être prendre des cinq
prendre b2 et salue karim khan
je parlais 5 sa fille stream que abdou
sow taux reviennent sur deco avec un
score qui jongle 12500 de temps passé
pour être si nul il aurait une bible
inquiète pas on est tous au même au même
fou hein moi aussi je me dis ça de moi
même
tant d'efforts pour être nulle c'est
ridicule ça l'est devenu moi je regarde
la partie un peu de sérieux s'il vous
plaît
à ces moments là ce qu'il veut faire il
veut faire tour prend b2 fou prend des
cinq dames prend des cinq tons prend 2,3
pour rejouer sur un autre clou âge
faut faire gaffe à jefferies parce que
là je sens qu'il en mode artistes aussi
voilà il ya fou prend g4 à regarder
maintenant ce qu'on attaque la dame et
si fait dame prend lioret tour g8 j'ai
l'impression que le niveau de jeu est
vraiment pas très haut là dernièrement
ça a très bien joué pendant un moment et
là j'ai l'impression que les deux
joueurs ont peut-être un petit coup de
fatigue aussi
il faut dire ça a tellement envoyée
après disons même à mon niveau en fait
c'est frustrant fait j'ai peut-être un
niveau plus frustrant que vous dans le
sens où moi je suis à un palier d'être
fort en faites pas je veux dire dans mon
talon potentiel en disant que j'aurais
pu arriver à 2005 2005 50 en admettant
en donnant beaucoup et comme j'ai déjà
dit ce n'était pas assez c'est pour ça
que j'ai bien fait d'arrêter
en fait j'étais à un palier de talent de
pouvoir arriver à 26,51 niveau
intéressant en fait j'aurais manqué un
palier
est ce que je pensais l'évolution de
pâtes égale wind et les dreads pourquoi
pas ou pas de rock ou ce qu'ils veulent
mais moi ça me dérangerait pas perso
j'suis pas forcément pour moi je pense
que l'évolution elle vient des cadences
et des formats et pas des règles moi je
pense que les règles des échecs sont
très bien et ce qui est mauvais c'est
les compétitions qu'on nous propose tous
les formats de compétition qu'on nous
propose mais si on fait évoluer les deux
mois ça me dérange pas ouais j'ai lu
l'article m'a pas du tout intéressé
posait quand vraie affaire fait autant
retourner des super machine sur un
caprice de kram nique pour faire ce qui
se passe quand on bouge les pions de
côté ça m'a pas l'air en ce moment
d'être le problème le problème du monde
en 2020 c'est pas le coronavirus ou où
la crise écologique c'est de savoir si
on peut bouger les pions de côté aux
échecs quoi c'est bon c'est c'est
vraiment le problème que qu'on se
demande tout cela on mauvaise partie de
giang damas est d'un match 7
c'est pour ça qu'il faut faire tourner
les superordinateurs d'intelligence
artificielle en 2020 c'est pour savoir
600 euros qu'est ce que ça donne quoi en
fait hein c'est c'est vraiment la
question essentielle si on bouge des
pions de deux cases au lieu d'une femme
on sait assez terrible en fait c'est
terrible donc là ces grandes variantes
de la catalane est quand même pendant
qu'on rigole qu'on discute qu'on s'amuse
abdou qui revient dans le match
il pourra quand même nourrir des regrets
un des partis où il en a un peu trop
fait ce qui pourrait honnêtement être à
-3 ici s'il avait un peu plus serré le
jeu
non mais c'est ouf en fait et si on
rajoute une pièce commence à diouf je
sais pas on m'en donnait à 5 l'idée
c'est qu'à et c6 qui est b4 tarn on est
la question dans le monde
qu'est ce qu'on s'en fout en fait de ce
qui se passe quand les enfin je sais pas
je sais pas à quel moment ça c'est
intéressant de savoir comment je voulais
partie quand on peut manger ses propres
pièces enfin oui ok pourquoi pas mais
bon ben qu'est ce qui se passe si le fou
au lieu de bouger en diagonale comme il
veut ils bougeront diagonale au maximum
que quatre cases
bah je sais pas c'est tout aussi oui le
janus enfin bon je sais pas en fait
cramique à quel moment en fait il a ses
idées là
tu vas te fait tourner les algorithmes
des à des superordinateurs pour savoir
des trucs mais mais enfin je comprends
pas en fait
qui ça intéresse en fait c'est cramique
depuis qu'il a arrêté les échecs en fait
écueil que il a plus besoin de garder
ses petits prépa il ya des idées quoi
non je sais pas en fait c il ad il a des
remorques de prépa dans ces ordis il
essaye de s'en débarrasser et quoi en
gros noms mais surtout pour quoi faire
tourner des super ordinateurs de google
qui consomment max d'électricité sert
que tu as atteint situe en france aussi
mes ancêtres marrons quoi d'un côté tac
rami qui fait ça et d'un autre côté on
devrait annuler le tour de france parce
que ça pollue trop quoi fin j'ai envie
de dire allons regarder ce que fait
cramique en premier lieu que devient
manu bah écoute forêt fois que je
l'appelle manu d'heure ça fait longtemps
que je n'ai pas eu
c'est une bonne question françois jack
est un bon moment où on va annuler le
tour de france parce que ça pollue trop
tableau qui te s'était fait une
pollution de ouf pour pour savoir un
truc qui intéresse personne quoi
tout question à nous faire
mais je comprends pas trop c'est juste
que j'ai eu beaucoup de gens qui étaient
complètement dithyrambique par rapport
par rapport à ce truc de cramé nique en
mode fantastique incroyable qu'est ce
qui se passe si le pion de bouche de
côté honnêtement moi c'est un truc c'est
ça ne m'intéresse pas en fait
bon abdou qui restent dans le match
fakir est ce qui reste à moins 5 il
reste une game là aux oraux aux impôts
pop up up guillon que sajoo 1 et et et
et et et hop hop hop hop hop hop
monsieur on revient
attention jefferies et encore une partie
attend qu est ce qui me fait la jeffry
je vais être obligé de sévir à
l'arbitrage
hop hop hop jazzy moi j'espère ça sent
le moins deux centièmes d'intérêt oui
pour moi rien est plus intéressant que
cette nouvelle en fait après il ya plein
de trucs intéressants à regarder dans
les échecs en fait de faire de regarder
dans des positions donner ce qu'on
pourrait jouer telle position datacard
qu'opposer nanani nanana il y aurait des
choses intéressantes à étudier pour la
peine mais la savoir savoir ce qui se
passe si le pion bouge en arrière ou
quoi enfin oui et de toute façon quand à
un jeu avec avec comme les échecs
je vous montre un truc généralement
quand vous avez des jo il ya beaucoup de
possibilités et où les deux camps ou une
position égal le joueur qui démarre n'a
pas vraiment davantage surtout avec
toutes les règles de possibilités de
nuls qu'on aux échecs
on sait très bien que même en changeant
les règles avec un échiquier
si les deux les deux camps ont les mêmes
règles normalement ça devrait quand même
mené à la nulle
mais en soit le résultat qu'on va avoir
avec ça à faire que des nuls on le
connaît d'avancé
c'est vrai c'est un monde parfait existe
sert à quoi alors il se trouve que
pioupious dans les mathématiques trouver
des solutions mathématiques à ce genre
de problèmes peuvent se permettre un
jour de faire des évolutions majeures
pour l'humanité
j'ai plus d'exemples concrets là dedans
parce que c'est pas mon domaine mais je
te conseille de regarder des chaînes
comme y penser ou quoi qui t'expliquent
parfois on a trouvé des trucs qui ont
été complètement inutiles en
mathématiques pendant des centaines
d'années et que tout d'un coup ça te
permet de faire des et l'évolution
extraordinaire qui permettent d'avoir
d'avoir tout un tas de choses à la
relativité qui a gps est un exemple mais
c'est un exemple simple des trucs plus
en plus profond qui ont vraiment servi à
rien pendant des centaines voire des
milliers d'années et tout d'un coup ça
permet de résoudre une équation qui
permet de faire un truc de ouf donc
il ya tout un ya tout un tas de cailloux
ça sert en fait comme je vous dis je
suis pas calé dans le sujet mais je sais
que ça sert à quelque chose
alors que savoir ce qui se passe dans
les échecs quand on bouge d'une pièce de
côté non la non là en fait non ça ne
sert à rien en fait ça et s'intéresse
son père moi j'ai trouvé au contraire
dommage que des gens qui ont des
contacts puisse utiliser ses ordinateurs
et ses technologies à ses fins la mais
après cccc c'est un avis perso encore
c'est un avis perso
voilà recherche fondamentale ccippp de
ce que j'ai pu lire c'est hyper utile
après je ne sais pas ça d'un pan du
personnel mais que via les via ce que
j'ai pu lire d'autres personnes quoi
pas le niveau pour le comprendre
ouais mais du tout c'est ça en fait dit
que moi j'ai pas trop compris c'est que
tout le monde était vraiment
dithyrambique de ce truc de cramé alors
que je sais pas
bizarre
bon écoutez ça va tout échange et ça va
faire nul mais abdou qui arrive pas à
juin trucks qui s'est trop lâché un
moment donné a donné des points il
aurait mieux fait de rester dans son
dans son truc
alors j'ai un peu le chat en lega
enfin écoutez c'est comme ça on n'y peut
rien
il rejoint un truc égal c'est ça
correspond plus à son psy la douce
autographes
abdou sato raf pardon et c'est dommage
qu'il ait autant d'écart au point quoi
moi alors et à plus serein rome qui
menace aussi d'avoir suivi un courageux
alors affaire h 4g 4 h 5
je serai bien sur ma chaîne a président
avec seb mazet
ça parle ma job son qui a beaucoup de
matches dans le tchat proposition 2 nuls
refusé par guy young ont refusé par
xiang a accepté par xiang
mais ça va être la dernière pause
non je vois que je vois qu'il ya des
mecs qui sont bons en maths dans le chat
tu avais pas fait des chèques ça a été
un sujet qui m'aurait a intéressé mais
je ne pense pas que j'aurais été très
très bon le nombre parfait facile 69
allait pas mal ça la pause est qu on
sent que qu'il ya des cons comme moi
dans le chat qui essaye de vivre de
petites de petites blagues de petits
larcins dans le chat pour essayer
d'exister face face aux 200 cuit en face
mais on est quand même larmes se bat
comme on peut on essaie d'exister
maxime humaine et un intérêt maximum
maxime brand matoussi ouais il m'a dit
qu'il était bon mais pas fou fou non
plus quoi il doit être très bon mais par
rapport aux échecs il est pas top top
quoi
qui on peut parler nfl on peut parler
rugby aussi un avec ce match ce match
annulé de castres contre contre
leicester terrible ça perdu sur tapis
vert à cause de 3,4 corona
ouais c'est quand même spécial ce match
c'est l'histoire des packers qui ont
fait les sacs fait ce qu'on peut la
victoire brillante du racing ouais mais
ça je m'y attendais à l'éclairement moi
ils ne paraissent pas si fort hein je
vous le dis dès clairement ils sont en
totale courbe descendante un nom mais
très franchement je vous dis très
franchement les gars clermont dès que tu
as plus un gâteau en forme ou quoi c'est
fini en fait y'a qu'à voir le match
contre toulouse en première journée où
ils ont failli se faire retourner à 15
contre 13
est ce que j'ai vu le match de tout j'ai
vu la première mi-temps est bas visitez
vraiment tellement au-dessus luxe dolce
terre
le petit col beef a fait un malheur avec
caen toulouse à la possession qui domine
devant et qui peuvent renvoyer la balle
sur l'ale dans de bonnes conditions à
colby et je pense qu'ils vont aller
gagner avec ses terrains
j'ai un peu vu le match et qu'ils
étaient 1 northampton honnêtement ça m'a
pas impressionné mais alors du tout
je vois pas examen existait rejet vous
moi je trouve pas si fort après par
contre les sarries ils vont être très
très chaud les saristes vont être très
dangereux je m'attendais à leur victoire
d'ailleurs au leinster mais ils ont
quand même des sacrés joueurs encore
lessard is quand tu mets quand même vous
ni poule à les frères vous ni poule a et
maronites ojjeh dans le pack d'avants
tata pour moi 3d
fatfat sont ses meilleurs meilleur
pilier vous ni poule à en huit believe
rooney poule à vacoas meilleurs piliers
du montre très clairement billy en 8
c'est un des tout meilleurs 8 du monde
mais il reste dans le top 3 et ito g que
tu le met en deuxième ligne en 4e en 5
ou que tu le met en troisième ligne aile
pour moi c'est sûr les deux passes et le
meilleur du monde de toute façon il est
il est impressionnant il sait tout faire
qu'est-ce appareils toi sur le live
accueille 2 go tag avec le rire jaune il
parlait de toi et de ton giga niveau
échec assez cool merci merci à vous et
merci à kiev du coup avec qui je
m'entends bien
non mais je vois pas quel les saracens
en fait quand à ces trois joueurs devant
et après ils ont d'autres très bons
avants c'est pas la question mais tata
déjà trois monstre absolu devant et
derrière c'est pas des charrettes les
mecs c'est pas des trompettes un donc
pour moi la finale ce sera toulouse
saracens les anglais sort de treyvaux
troisième ligne en ce moment et qui
peuvent jouer deuxième ligne en plus
d'ailleurs il se passe quoi si les
saristes gagne la coupe d'europe il a
rejoint l'année prochaine où ils sont
quand même relégué sans coupe d'europe
on peut se poser
normalement ils doivent la jouer mais je
ne sais pas on verra et on n'a pas fait
le débrief de pau gatcha encore regard
impressionnant numéro 8
avec son équipe il a il est trop trop
assuré c'est intéressant de voir s'il ya
des joueurs pros de rugby que josé
chacun a sûrement me sera cool de
réussir à avoir mon fils gaël galant en
live en guise fait finalisé en beauté
ray qu'est ce qui nous fait exergue ses
parkings
qu'est ce qui me fait un faux faut
arrêter tout de suite là mon garçon faut
arrêter tout de suite là attention hein
il date prévue avec mon fils n'y a pas
de date précise mais j'imagine qui aura
rien avant
j'imagine qui aura rien avant roland
garros il m'a dit qu'ils me recontactent
aurait aimé y aura rien avant roland je
pense je connais pas la saison de tennis
après derrière roland ou son emploi du
temps mais là j'imagine que pendant les
mois à venir
pendant les semaines à venir il doit
dans le dur après je sais je sais pas ce
qui ce ski se jouait ce que les tournois
en asie se joue pas je n'en sais rien
ouais pineau pineau il a perdu dans la
médecine aux deux façons il a perdu dans
la chute mais il aurait il aurait pas eu
le niveau pour pour gagner à pour gagner
le tour cette année il était trop fort
ouais je sais pas ce qu'il ya comme
roland après roland comme tout raté
hills
paref yoel et les saristes peuvent pas
gagner leur titre c'est ce que ce que
j'avais cru comprendre dans le sens où
il ya personne qui parlait des saris
l'année prochaine en coupe d'europe
quand un but from monter le vent toi et
si on veut voir on peut voir pougatchev
a gagné le forez et le tour d'italie du
coup moi je pense que c'est simone yates
qui va être favori du tour du giro après
toujours pareil j'en sais rien toujours
pareil j'en sais rien mais moi je vois
bien
déjà je vois bien ou devant arte
greentomatocars into my ineo sujet sans
perte de vitesse
je vois pas ineos gagner un tour cette
année je ne les vois pas gagner cette
année
je crois que qui lancé leur manager
portal qui est décédé way ou qu'ils
aient eu un problème qui n'est plus là
et depuis qu'il est parti
c'est difficile parce qu'il a eu j'ai
décidé mais j'en sais rien en vrai un
portal est décédé depuis que depuis
qu'ils ont plus portal ils sont dans le
dur
ouais ils sont dans le dur devant un art
aux championnats du monde
ouais enfin je suis assez d'accord me
sera favori après la la pancarte 1 mais
bon la chance qui peut avoir c'est qu'il
ya à la faucille qui à la pancarte et je
pense que vous en art est légèrement
plus fort que kadhaf cette saison ça
peut lui servir
après deux mandats il faut aussi faire
gaffe un marc hirschi ci s'est bien
remis de sa chute et à tom dumoulin
tom dumoulin je le sens dangereux aussi
ouais bon art le problème c'est que
personne n'a vouloir collaborer avec lui
un saint est infernal evans paul sera au
giro adam khel dans quelles conditions
mais tom du moins il peut être dangereux
il a quand même fait une grosse fin de
tour de france il fait 2e du dernier
contre-la-montre pour moi ça peut être
un danger
après avoir annoncé rien mais à la
philippe je donne quasiment aucune
chance en vrai je les trouvais en perte
de vitesse sur la fin du tour je le vois
pas je le vois pas faire quoi que ce
soit bon allez on va regarder cette fin
de bullet cette fin de match aller
normalement il ya huit à neuf parties
quand le match sera mathématiquement
fini on partira tiens il joue dans ce
répertoire on partira sur sur l'autre
live donc elle joue la variante à la
mode avec le fou g4 et jefferies qui a
l'air d'être surpris faux h5 comprend là
dessus ces dames des quatre échecs fou
prend dame france et 3 et ça c'est assez
chiant à jouer avec les blancs en vrai
tomber un dame prend ses 6 ouf ou g6 et
en réalité ça donne rien du tout why
even cool c'est le gars qui s'est gaufré
qui c'est qui s'est cassé le bassin rey
s'est pas cassé les jambes mais s'est
cassé le bassin ouais donc petites
positions assez égal et jefferies qui il
doit vouloir gérer son match en fait il
a il a besoin de faire ci fait cinq nuls
4 défaites ils gagnent le match donc il
gère et là en plus il eut place une
tactique il n'a pas du tout vu sa abdou
il a raté pour ces trois tours penser
cette pré la plus des lots aussi en
bullet à jefferies donc il doit pouvoir
être tranquille
s'ils gagnent cette partie passa plus si
c'est ça va être quasiment
mathématiquement terminée déjà le match
pourrait faire un petit tour france et 7
g pas relancer le chrono malheureusement
on va imaginer qu'il ya eu deux minutes
de jeu je suis en train de mettre le
chrono mais à la partie qui tourne
vraiment très bien maintenant pour
jefferies qui va avoir tout simplement
match gagné 1 les amis
ce que là il va pouvoir gagner il va
pouvoir aller gagner g7
ouais la partie qui qui va se terminer
sur fois ci s'il va voir cf6 dame prend
et tour d un math aller vers un petit
fou h6 qui attaquent la tour et qui
menacent dame g7 mat
c'était le piège abdou qui se prend et
ça va faire 1 0 donc le score qui
recommencent à enfler sahara il reprend
les six points d'avance il reprend sa
marche en avant
jefferies gong mais il est très très
très facile un mois je vous comment je
vous commente le but est tranquille si
apparemment il n'ya pas y'a pas de
raison de s'en fout s'enflammer il n'y a
pas de match haas et c'est gagné un
torrent de la cam n'a pas marché non
c'est vrai qu'on aura vécu de nouveau un
match qui malheureusement va pas motiver
les gens à regarder d'autres matches
pourtant les débuts de match sont
intéressants mais voilà il ya trop de
vent je me refais rue sera une
opposition très égale ça va sûrement
partir sur une news ça convient à vision
gains il a en gestion
il n'a pas besoin d'en faire trop abouti
pourra regretter quand même son petit
craquage après ils étaient ils étaient
en dessous on l'a bien vu truc c'est
qu'il hante son bull est donc de toute
façon il était il n'y avait pas de cas
de figure où il terminait devant 5 + 1
et 3 + 1 vision qui a été trop impérial
et une fourchette raté oui possible
ces exemples qui met de nouveau la
pression des 5 c 5 alors il va fixer le
pion en d5
il va essayer de le prendre
ces présidents ce pas aussi dramatique
non à la correction de gamer elle était
vraiment là c'est pas une correction
c'est juste il est moins fort il ya un
peu moins fort en fait il serait pas
corrigé il est juste un peu moins fort
il est juste un peu moins fort là c'est
pas une correction modérée dame prend
des cinq étoiles et prendrait 5 après ça
commence a mal tourné là et détroit et
l'idée sur dame prend ses quartiers
d'amiens d'emprunt f2 aidé à me deux
dames c'est 3 3 6 et après il fera des
deux des 1
des deux rois et fuit 3g ok c'est bien
joué ça même si ça doit aller ça allait
dernier fut trois ici dame ici f6 ff6 là
dessus sur dan des 5 3-6 le retour ya
plus d'échecs et sur hk 3g 4 dan 17 f 5
ouais f k 3,5 sarrois ici dame prend 3
prend h30 à pranger 4 elle va pouvoir
raser tous les pions ouais c'est bien
joué
ahmed hammache 3 encore adam prendre 17
il a fait un échec mais maintenant il ya
d'amener un des 1 au prochain
c'est fini et là je crois que c'est
mathématiquement finir déjà le match 7
points 23 minutes près forêt qui gagne
tout en jouant rapidement mais si xiang
en gagnant encore une c'est vraiment
fini c'est fini pour le match qui aurait
été pas qui est pliée depuis depuis
19h20 on va dire à peu près c'est
terrible et là il se prend foulée 5
ouais bon il y ait plus il est plus dans
la tête
abdou là il y ait plus il n'y ait plus
notre ami notre ami ouzbek a bon dos la
partie abandonné match devrait racheter
it
franchement là c'est ouais je sais kings
c'est cool que kiev du rire jaune et et
parler de la chaîne je passe s'amener
défouloir d'ailleurs je le tarnais façon
les amis tout a été dit sur ce match sur
les petites partie pédagogique derrière
or il ya masse de gens qui ont foulé la
chaîne d'admiration vrais c pa du huawei
je pense qu à 21h20 je vais lancer
l'autre là c'est mathématiquement fini
cette fois-ci là c'est sûr qu'il y aura
pas une vingtaine tu peux pas y avoir
une partie c'est impossible donc le
match est vraiment déjà plié ouais alors
c'est quand les prochains speech a jeté
un oeil
alors sixtine na na nana na na le
prochain match sera smirnov contreras
doissat d'oignies et ce sera le 23
mercredi à 18 heures après les quarts de
finale tout un programme
tout un programme
alors encore masse de match jose après
certains
je suis en train de regarder le l'emploi
du temps si vous me voyez un beat hâtif
je regardais vie sociale officielle à
nicher le blitz et pour commenter hier
qu'il faisait des blitz a pendant le
match non turcs et ouais après c'est un
style de commentaire
ben saada été gagné par abdou sur un
match du couloir il n'y avait pas grand
monde non qui suivait calmes hier non
plus il y avait comme aujourd'hui en
fait c'est c'est terrible
c'est terrible
ouais robert arrive à garder de
l'intérêt trop fort je sais pas je sais
pas comment il fait je sais pas comment
il fait ok la foux prend 1,4 qui prend
1,4 prend un quartier pour 1 4 6 et 4
ans dans b2c que celui qu on donne un
coup toujours le sort en herbe
pourquoi pas mais bon
pourquoi pas après là il va peut-être
d'amaya damage cistac et peut-être
simple areva prend des cats est vrai
sinon c'était joli
mais après c'est difficile a carrément
peu de compétition qui a qui continuent
comme ça dans quelques états d'âme
projet c'est de savoir jamais voilà
c'est parti au regard des tranchées dans
les parties et bonsoir cette grave
bon ça joue rapidement un an des deux
côtés ça joue vite quand même hein c'est
impressionnant abdullah qui refait des
bonnes parties hiller réussi par grappes
en fait à mettre son adversaire sous
pression
c'est joli là et tour c'est un matin par
able aller c'est bien ça fait plaisir
qu'ils reviennent un petit peu
d'exemples qui est très fair play il
fait pas tourner la pendule il pourrait
mais il ne le fait pas et c'est tout à
son honneur en suggérant avons stoppé au
contraire continuer à
alors là qu'est ce qu'il a fait comme
conneries bah oui l'iphone 4 ça hyper
l'option b 4 bat les candidats ils
reprennent le 1er novembre normalement
et salue rené 98e chacun quelques
minutes bah écoute ya y accueillons
qu'april avantage un avantage décisif en
début de ronde et but de bullet puis là
il a un peu baissé le yep et donc il y
en a reperdu 2 mais bon il garde le
contrôle du match
totalement
il garde un contrôle total du match
ouais là abdou du coup pierre abandonne
ce qui était complètement foutu on a on
l'a vu un gris masse et quand tu es un
espion b4 et s'adonner la partie et ça
fait 15 8 donc là c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment du hourra échec car les deux
joueurs qui ont perdus consécutivement
sur sur des matchs du couloir raté dont
deux pièces ou de pions en un là on sent
que les deux sont plus plus vraiment
concernés sont peut-être un petit peu
fatiguée un peu de lassitude action qui
a été obligé de resserrer un tout petit
peu la vis pour pour reprendre
l'avantagé
toutes les parties se jouer rapidement
mais là-bas sept points d'écart 15
minutes de jeu il se prend maintenant le
fou prend 6 très thématique abdou que
tout le monde connaît le gros piège les
écossaises quatre cavaliers terrible
donc il va sûrement la reperdre celle-là
apparaître actions de revenir à
l'avantagé maximal qu'il avait eue
pendant le match c'est à dire plus 8
bref 4 il va récupérer en b 8 7 petites
tactiques lui a permis d'échanger du
matériel fou prend h3 alors sur pions
proie et le tour prend b8 j'imagine les
blancs on faire bnf 4 pour pour jouer
fou aux 5 et ça va être de nouveau
terminé je ressens que les joueurs
calcul plus rien ils envoient et puis ça
marche ça marche ça marche pas ça marche
pas cette fois ci ça ne marchait pas et
abdou qui va de nouveau s'incliner prend
1,7 qui menace maintenant food et 4 par
deux fois en jeu 3 du coût
il va se venger sur le fou en c7 il
résiste encore bien défendu il oblige
les blancs à mal se place et ils
réussissent même pas à sauver le
matériel alors il part en c3 il reste
quoi en plus y'a deux pions de plus bon
en partie longue je pense que ce serait
vraiment gagnant pour les blancs mais là
avec un roi un petit peu ouvert il peut
toujours arriver des choses
pourquoi sa fille par le bull est alors
la logique si que tu va rigoler tu va
rigoler c'est de garder le plus
longtemps possible dans le match du
suspense en fait l'idée c'est de se dire
qu'avec le bullet ça laisse toujours une
chance à un joueur de revenir et donc il
ya du suspense jusqu'à la dernière
seconde du match
tech w ouais c'est ça l'idée en fait
c'est d'avoir un format vraiment qu'ils
maintiennent le suspense tout au long
des quatre heures il se prend le f 4
échecs
pour avoir un format excitant et avec du
suspense jusqu'au bout
mission remplie
zoug michel est pour le maintien du
suspense est donc à douche qui était un
peu revenu sur des erreurs d'occasion
qui avait laissé filer un petit peu j'ai
envie de dire mais à mes questions qui
s'est tout de suite remis qui s'est tout
de suite remis et qui après ses deux
défaites enchaînées par trois victoires
consécutives
du coup je pense pas qu'on a eu on va
faire comme la dernière fois je pense je
vais mettre la pub on va pas aller au
bout du match je vais envoyer le stream
sur bitstream histoires comme ça que
j'en vois le truc machin et où on perd
pas de temps et au moins on fait pas
attendre maso je pense que le match à
partir d'ici n'a plu énormément
d'intérêt pour les spectateurs
ça fait déjà quand même deux heures un
peu plus de deux heures maintenant qu'on
connaît déjà le vainqueur du match je
pense qu'on va arrêter là et comme ça on
va faire les parties pédagogique avec
cette base est comme ça je vous mets la
petite la petite transition
dp pouces quoi
regarde jusqu'à la fin de cette partie
et puis après on je vous fais le raid
vous fait tout comme il faut
roy ya trop de suspense à insérer que le
il ya tellement de suspense conçu un
dans ce match
qui nous aura vraiment émoustillé c'est
la chanteuse soul c'est terrible je
viens avec ses sarcasmes va exclure
jolie dame 3f de réalité surtout prendre
5 pour prendre 5 n'y avait pas foule
ravie de ce été cloué et on va essayer
d'attaquer le roi alors là oui tour f1
puis d'un prendre ici c'est n'importe
quoi ce café xiang
il refait sa grimace un peu bizarre faut
lui dire d'arrêter à la grimace comme ça
enfin l'aïe a paraît il resterait cette
partie nord menace est à 26 1 9
non il ya sept points d'écart faut pas
qu'il fasse à sa faute au thunder zynga
et non tout à fait bon alors du coup on
va changer de nom va changer de place
violence et le live de l'autre côté et
on se retrouve on se retrouve dans
quelques secondes
rester ici vous aurez le raid qui va
partir et moi j'arrive avec maso dans à
peu près 10 15 minutes à tous